I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道现在才年初，但我们已经在讨论暑假的家庭旅行了。你知道我们喜欢住爱彼迎（Airbnb）。我知道。嗯，我们喜欢有厨房，我喜欢早上穿着睡袍走出来喝杯茶，正如你所说的，珍娜，我喜欢一段长长的跑道。是的。嗯，你知道，李现在在俄克拉荷马州工作，我们要去探望他，他为我们全家订了一个非常好的爱彼迎住处。这样我们就可以分散开来，每个人都能睡个好觉。然后你会感觉就像在家里一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah.
即使你身处不同的城市。天哪，我可不想和全家人睡在一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了酒店了。是的，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。是的，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，一个真正的冰箱。你知道的，我喜欢吃零食。我确实知道这一点。是的，我不想叫客房服务。我想要它们就在手边。没错。是的。
Everyone we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. pepper sauce poured with ease, and if smoky strips of bacon make burgers better, you'll love our cheesy jalapeno and bacon quarter pounder. Get this beefy, bold, bacony, melty mouthful only at McDonald's for a limited time. Hello everyone and welcome to our second drink of Boys and Girls. This episode is near and dear to our hearts because we got to have all the ladies in scenes together all day and this episode was directed by the legendary Denny Gordon. Yes. And, you know, Boys and Girls is on Dave Rogers' list of favorite Peacock superfan episodes. Yep.
各位，我想我们都是爱彼迎的忠实用户，对于你的下一次冒险或下一次度假，也许可以考虑爱彼迎。胡椒酱轻松淋下，如果烟熏培根条能让汉堡更美味，那你一定会爱上我们的芝士墨西哥辣椒培根四分之一磅汉堡。限时供应，快来麦当劳品尝这口肉香四溢、大胆浓郁、培根味十足、芝士融化的美味吧。大家好，欢迎来到我们的第二杯《男孩与女孩》。这一集对我们来说意义非凡，因为我们让所有的女士们整天都在场景中一起拍摄，这一集是由传奇人物丹妮·戈登执导的。是的。而且，你知道，《男孩与女孩》在戴夫·罗杰斯的孔雀台超级粉丝最爱剧集名单上。没错。
So we actually reached out to the director of Boys and Girls, Denny Gordon, and we are going to have her on Office Ladies as our special guest to talk all about the Superfan episode. I really can't wait for it, and we'll let you know when that's coming out. So we aren't going to give any new insights on this episode today. You'll have to wait for our Superfan breakdown for that. But we didn't want to leave you hanging, so I thought we could answer a question from our general mailbox. Great.
所以我们联系了《男孩与女孩》的导演丹妮·戈登，我们将邀请她作为特别嘉宾来到《办公室女士》节目，聊聊关于这一集超级粉丝的内容。我真的迫不及待了，我们会通知大家它什么时候播出。所以我们今天不会对这一集提供任何新的见解。你们得等到我们的超级粉丝解析节目才能听到。但我们不想让你们干等着，所以我想我们可以回答一个来自我们公共邮箱的问题。太棒了。
This came in from Avery C. in Richmond, Virginia, who said, Hello, Jenna and Angela. I would love to know about rehearsals. When did you do rehearsals? How did they fit in the general schedule of the week? Filming, getting lighting, locations. Did you rehearse each scene every day?
这个问题来自弗吉尼亚州里士满的艾弗里·C，她说，你好，珍娜和安吉拉。我很想了解关于排练的事情。你们什么时候排练？它们是如何安排在一周的总日程里的？拍摄、灯光、场地。你们每天都要排练每一场戏吗？
Or did you front load all the rehearsals at the beginning of the week? Did you wear your costume and makeup the rehearsals at the beginning of the week? Did you wear your costume and makeup for rehearsals or ordinary clothes? How long did rehearsals usually take? Basically, Avery wants the full download on rehearsals. Well, Avery, I think this is a great question. You know, every single show or movie you work on is a little different. And our show, we typically did a rehearsal for camera and for the actor and directors. And we weren't always in wardrobe for those. Depending on where your call time was and where you were in the mix of the day,
还是你们把所有的排练都安排在一周的开始？你们在排练时会穿戏服和化妆吗，还是穿平时的衣服？排练通常需要多长时间？基本上，艾弗里想要关于排练的完整内幕。嗯，艾弗里，我觉得这是一个很好的问题。你知道，你参与的每一部剧或电影都有点不同。在我们的剧中，我们通常会为摄像机以及演员和导演进行一次排练。我们并不总是穿着戏服进行排练。取决于你的通告时间以及你在当天拍摄进度中的位置，
you might be halfway through hair and makeup. You might be fully dressed because you had already been in a scene that day. But we would always walk through the scene for the camera crew and the lighting crew. Yes, and those rehearsals would happen right before we shot that scene. So it's not like we came in on Monday mornings and rehearsed everything in a big clump. Whatever scene we were getting ready to shoot, it would begin with a rehearsal. And we would all sit and sometimes even get out our scripts and read through it, talk about where we thought each person would stand or how they would cross or move, and play out the beats of the scene. Camera would figure out how they were going to cover it.
你可能还在做发型和化妆。你可能已经穿好了戏服，因为你当天已经拍过一场戏了。但我们总是会为摄影组和灯光组走一遍戏。是的，这些排练通常就在我们拍摄那场戏之前进行。所以并不是说我们周一早上来，然后把所有东西都排练一遍。无论我们准备拍哪场戏，都会以排练开始。我们都会坐下来，有时甚至拿出剧本通读一遍，讨论我们认为每个人应该站在哪里，或者他们应该如何走位或移动，并演绎出场景的节奏。摄影组会弄清楚他们将如何拍摄。
And that was the rehearsal. It was not usually even done for performance. No, hardly ever done for performance. Really more of a walkthrough for the crew. And what I always did when I had bigger scenes with a lot of dialogue is I just rehearsed like crazy on my own in my trailer. Sometimes Jenna and I would meet and run lines together or whoever you might be in a scene with.
这就是排练。它通常甚至不是为了表演而做的。不，几乎从来不是为了表演。更多的是为了剧组的走位。当我遇到有很多台词的大场面时，我总是会在自己的拖车里疯狂地排练。有时珍娜和我会在场景中一起对台词，或者和你一起演戏的任何人。
Phyllis and I, I remember we would rehearse many of our big scenes where our two characters had conflict. Well, when you work on a television show or a movie, you are expected to do all of that work at home. That is your homework. You're meant to come in prepared, with your lines ready, your choices made. The rehearsal process on a movie or a television show
我记得菲利斯和我，我们会排练许多我们两个角色有冲突的大场面。嗯，当你参与电视剧或电影工作时，你被要求在家里完成所有这些工作。那是你的家庭作业。你应该准备好，台词背熟，做出你的表演选择。电影或电视剧的排练过程
is not there for you to make any acting discoveries, necessarily. And sometimes it's your very first time hearing how the other actor in the scene is doing their part. Which is super weird. So of course on The Office, we got to know each other so well. I could just hear how Angela was gonna say it
并不是为了让你做出任何表演上的发现。有时这是你第一次听到场景中的另一位演员如何演绎他们的部分。这非常奇怪。所以当然在《办公室》里，我们彼此非常了解。我能听出安吉拉会怎么说，
or how Brian Baumgartner was gonna say something as Kevin. But you know, on other movies, sometimes you're meeting your scene partner that you're supposed to have this long character history with for the first time in that little rehearsal right before you shoot. Yeah. But then you do the rehearsal and then there'll be a little break. So you do get a chance to kind of download that information. And during that break, you're meant to get into your wardrobe or get your hair and makeup touched up and then that's when the lighting crew will come in and they'll
或者布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳会怎么以凯文的身份说些什么。但你知道，在其他电影中，有时你是在拍摄前的那次小排练中，第一次见到你本应有很长角色历史的对手戏演员。是的。但随后你会进行排练，然后会有一个小休息。所以你确实有机会消化这些信息。在那次休息期间，你应该换上戏服或补妆，然后灯光组就会进来，他们会
make sure that everything's ready and that's about a 30 minute break on our set, sometimes less. Yeah. And sometimes the physicality of the scene doesn't end up being the way you thought it was going to be. I remember there was a scene from Accounting where I interject into a conversation that's happening in the bullpen. And when I read it, I thought, oh, I probably get up and I walk over to the bullpen.
确保一切准备就绪，在我们的片场这大约有30分钟的休息时间，有时更短。是的。有时场景的肢体动作最终并不像你想象的那样。我记得会计部有一场戏，我插话进入正在发生的对话中。当我读剧本时，我想，哦，我可能会站起来走到会计部。
But the way they were framing the wide shot, Randall Einhorn had me yell my line from Accounting. And that sort of changed how I said it. It had a bigger presence in the room. So you kind of have to have some flexibility in how you rehearsed it on your own at home and to how it's gonna end up being that day on set. Yeah, well Avery, thank you for that question. Yes, thank you so much for writing in
但他们构图广角镜头的方式，兰德尔·艾因霍恩让我从会计部大喊我的台词。这在某种程度上改变了我说话的方式。它在房间里有了更大的存在感。所以你必须在家里排练的方式和当天在片场最终呈现的效果之间保持一定的灵活性。是的，好吧，艾弗里，谢谢你的提问。是的，非常感谢你的来信，
and be sure to catch our Peacock super fan breakdown of Boys and Girls with director amazing Denny Gordon later this year. But first, here is our original breakdown of Boys and Girls with director, amazing, Denny Gordon later this year. But first, here is our original breakdown of Boys and Girls. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
一定要在今年晚些时候收看我们关于《男孩与女孩》的孔雀台超级粉丝解析，嘉宾是了不起的导演丹妮·戈登。但首先，这是我们最初对《男孩与女孩》的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hey gang.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。嘿，伙计们。
Hello everybody. I'm wearing my Office Ladies hoodie today. You really are. I am holding a note card. It's almost like I wanna play it. I'm like in a poker game. I'm like ready to drop it. It's your ace of spades.
大家好。我今天穿着我的《办公室女士》连帽衫。你确实穿着。我手里拿着一张笔记卡。感觉就像我想打牌一样。就像在扑克游戏中，我准备把它扔出来。这是你的黑桃A。
Drop it like it's hot. Drop it like it's hot. Drop it like it's hot. But it says Angela Sass. It does. And there's a lot of Angela Sass in this episode. So you're ready to play that sass. I'm ready because I know you have your stuff you're going to say, but I'm holding an Angela Sass.
扔得火热。扔得火热。扔得火热。但上面写着“安吉拉的傲慢”。确实。这一集里有很多“安吉拉的傲慢”。所以你准备好展现那种傲慢了。我准备好了，因为我知道你有你要说的东西，但我手里拿着“安吉拉的傲慢”。
It's coming in hot. Today we're talking about Boys and Girls, season two, episode 15 written by BJ Novak and directed by Denny Gordon, badass Denny Gordon. Yeah, she's back. Should I read a summary? Do it. All right. Jan hosts a Women in the Workplace seminar with the women of the office, but Michael feels threatened. So he decides to throw a competing men in the workplace seminar down in the warehouse, which he slowly destroys. Fast fact number one fan question from Dan Felve. Was the idea for this episode based on anything that anyone went through like in a previous
它来势汹汹。今天我们要谈论的是《男孩与女孩》，第二季第15集，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，丹妮·戈登执导，了不起的丹妮·戈登。是的，她回来了。我应该读一下摘要吗？读吧。好的。简在办公室的女性中举办了一场“职场女性”研讨会，但迈克尔感到受到了威胁。所以他决定在仓库里举办一场竞争性的“职场男性”研讨会，结果他慢慢地毁掉了它。第一个事实，来自丹·费尔夫的粉丝提问。这一集的想法是基于任何人经历过的类似以前的
job? No, Dan, it's based on an idea that Angela and I pitched. That's right, Dan. Dan. This is our proudest moment. We love this. We love this. Also, we love that Greg Daniels was so collaborative, right?
工作吗？不，丹，它是基于安吉拉和我提出的一个想法。没错，丹。丹。这是我们最自豪的时刻。我们喜欢这个。我们喜欢这个。此外，我们喜欢格雷格·丹尼尔斯如此乐于合作，对吧？
Yeah. That we could have this idea. So, you know, Jen and I both worked in corporate America. And so we both had to go to a lot of like human resource meetings and things like that. And we were on set one day sort of talking about it and I wrote about it in my journal. Lady, I did too.
是的。我们可以有这个想法。所以，你知道，珍和我都曾在企业界工作过。所以我们都不得不参加很多像人力资源会议之类的事情。有一天我们在片场谈论这件事，我把它写在了我的日记里。天哪，我也写了。
I wrote on Thursday, February 2nd, 2006, boys and girls, there are many things I love about working on this show, but one of the coolest is the creative input that we get to have. A lot of shows just don't let their actors get involved that way. But Jen and I were talking about our lives before the show. When she was a secretary and I was an operator
我写道：2006年2月2日，星期四，《男孩与女孩》，关于这部剧的工作有很多我喜欢的地方，但最酷的事情之一就是我们能够提供的创意投入。很多剧集根本不让演员以那种方式参与。但珍和我在谈论我们拍戏前的生活。当她是秘书，我是接线员时，
and we were laughing about all the crazy seminars and ridiculous meetings we had to sit through at our old corporate jobs. We sort of had this idea that it would be a funny episode called Women in the Workplace. We ran into Greg Daniels and told him our little idea. We didn't have anything flushed out or written down and he got so excited.
我们笑着谈论我们在旧公司工作中不得不参加的所有疯狂研讨会和荒谬会议。我们有了一个想法，觉得拍一集叫《职场女性》的剧会很有趣。我们遇到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，告诉了他我们的小想法。我们没有任何详细的计划或写下来的东西，他却非常兴奋。
He grabbed BJ and he said, start writing this down. And BJ got a notepad and started jotting things down. Greg started scribbling notes too. Weeks later BJ Novak wrote this awesome script. Jenna and I were so excited. We are so lucky to be a part of a show that would respect our ideas. Oh that is so nice. You wrote mostly about the collaboration. I wrote very differently about this in my journal. Wait, can I say the last thing I wrote was, to any of the writers out there, we're not going to get in the habit of just bugging you guys with ideas.
他抓住了BJ，说，开始写下来。BJ拿了一个记事本开始记下东西。格雷格也开始乱涂乱画笔记。几周后，BJ·诺瓦克写出了这个很棒的剧本。珍娜和我非常兴奋。我们很幸运能参与一部尊重我们想法的剧。哦，那真是太好了。你主要写的是合作。我关于这一点的日记写得很不一样。等等，我可以最后说一句吗，我写的是：对于任何编剧，我们不会养成只是用想法去烦你们的习惯。
I know. We would always have these bright ideas as a cast and we always worried that we annoyed the writers, but they were always so receptive and nice, even if they were pretending. Okay, so what did you write about? Okay. I went on a very elaborate description of where we were when we came up with the idea for this episode. Where were we? We were in my trailer. We were having a picnic lunch. Oh my gosh. I described that we had scented candles. I love our two different accounts of this moment in time. Scented candles and that we were discussing it.
我知道。作为演员，我们总是会有这些好点子，我们总是担心会惹恼编剧，但他们总是非常乐于接受和友好，即使他们是在假装。好吧，那你写了什么？好的。我非常详细地描述了我们想出这一集想法时我们在哪里。我们在哪里？我们在我的拖车里。我们在吃野餐午餐。天哪。我描述了我们有香薰蜡烛。我喜欢我们对这一时刻的两种不同描述。香薰蜡烛，我们在讨论它。
And I also wrote that we did this all the time. We would have these ladies lunches. And during this ladies lunch, we got the bright idea for this episode that we ran onto the set that we set it to Greg Daniels, same as you. He pulled BJ aside and BJ's like, oh my gosh, what is this episode idea? And we said, here's what it is. The idea is that Jan comes in and has a woman in the workplace seminar and then Michael gets jealous and he says, I want a man in the workplace seminar. And BJ's like, I love it. What happens next?
我还写道我们经常这样做。我们会举行这些女士午餐。在这次女士午餐期间，我们想出了这一集的绝妙主意，我们跑向片场，像你一样告诉了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。他把BJ拉到一边，BJ说，天哪，这是什么剧集想法？我们说，就是这样。想法是简进来举办一个职场女性研讨会，然后迈克尔嫉妒了，他说，我想要一个职场男性研讨会。BJ说，我喜欢。接下来发生什么？
And we're like, we don't know. That's it. That's all we got. He's like, that's it. That's the whole thing. We're like, yeah. And he's like, okay, I have a lot of work to do. And BJ filled in all the blanks. All the rest. Fast fact number two.
我们说，我们不知道。就是这样。这就是我们所有的内容。他说，就是这样？这就是全部内容？我们说，是的。他说，好吧，我有很多工作要做。然后BJ填补了所有空白。剩下的所有内容。第二个事实。
Another fan question from Elani Swentzel. One of my favorite things is watching you read people's Twitter or Instagram handles. Alani asked, were the scenes in the warehouse and the scenes in the conference room filmed at separate times? If so, where were the other cast members during that time? We got a lot of questions about this. People wanted to know, did we have two different film crews? How did this work?
另一个来自埃拉尼·斯文泽尔的粉丝提问。我最喜欢的事情之一就是看你读人们的推特或Instagram账号。埃拉尼问，仓库里的场景和会议室里的场景是分开拍摄的吗？如果是这样，其他演员当时在哪里？我们收到了很多关于这个的问题。人们想知道，我们是否有两个不同的摄制组？这是怎么运作的？
No, one we have two different film crews? How did this work? No, one film crew. There were a couple of days where all of the women came to work and we shot our scenes. And then there were a couple of days where all the men came to work. I don't know what I did, but I had the day off. And I remember it was glorious. This was rare. Yeah, no, I remember being really excited. First of all, there was just a day where it was just all us gals and it was really fun.
不，我们有两组摄制组？这是怎么运作的？不，一个摄制组。有几天所有的女性都来上班，我们拍摄了我们的场景。然后有几天所有的男性都来上班。我不知道我做了什么，但我那天休息。我记得那真是太棒了。这很少见。是的，不，我记得非常兴奋。首先，有一天只有我们这些女孩，这真的很有趣。
I wrote about that in my diary as well. And I think part of the inspiration for this episode came from our desire to do more scenes together and be with the other women in the office doing scenes. And so it was a really fun week, not just because we got to hang out with the gals, but also we did have half the week off, which was really cool. And then we had one day where we were all together to film the scenes where the boys and girls are all together. I know, and I remember we were kind of excited to see everybody, we were like, hey! Yeah, how's Ben?
我也在日记里写了那个。我认为这一集的灵感部分来自于我们想要一起拍更多场景，并与其他办公室女性一起拍戏的愿望。所以那是非常有趣的一周，不仅因为我们可以和女孩们在一起，而且我们确实有一半时间休息，这真的很酷。然后我们有一天大家聚在一起拍摄男孩和女孩都在一起的场景。我知道，我记得我们看到大家时有点兴奋，我们说，嘿！是的，本怎么样？
What happened down there? We'd been on summer vacation or something. Okay. Fast fact number three, this episode is Jim and Pam's first fight. It's a real fight. Yeah, this is a real fight. Now they got into a little bit of a,
下面发生了什么？我们好像在过暑假什么的。好的。第三个事实，这一集是吉姆和帕姆的第一次争吵。这是一场真正的争吵。是的，这是一场真正的争吵。现在他们陷入了一点点，
what would you call it, a disagreement in the episode, the fight, when Jim picks her up at the dojo. Well, they've had a few bumpy moments. This is a fight, it's not resolved, we'll get into it. But it's a, yeah, they had some harsh words at each other. This is also another episode where Jim and Pam are basically separated the entire episode. So now we've had two episodes in a row where they're physically separated. In the last
你会怎么称呼它，在《争吵》那一集中，当吉姆在道场接她时，他们产生了一点分歧。嗯，他们经历了一些坎坷的时刻。这是一场争吵，没有解决，我们会深入探讨。但这是一个，是的，他们对彼此说了些刻薄的话。这也是吉姆和帕姆基本上整集都分开的另一集。所以现在我们连续两集他们都在身体上分开了。在上一集
episode, Pam and Roy were really getting along. And now in this episode, Jim and Pam get in a fight. I mean, we're building tension. We're building tension. We don't know what's happening with Dwight and Angela. They probably found a part of the day to sneak off and hook up. I think that that's probably true. Well, those are the end of my fast facts. Why are you holding Angela Sass still?
帕姆和罗伊相处得很好。现在在这一集中，吉姆和帕姆吵架了。我的意思是，我们在制造紧张感。我们在制造紧张感。我们不知道德怀特和安吉拉发生了什么。他们可能找了一天中的某个时间溜出去约会了。我想这可能是真的。好吧，这就是我事实的结尾。你为什么还拿着“安吉拉的傲慢”？
OK, I'm waiting. Are we going to break, or are you going to Angela Sass me first? I'm going to Angela Sass you before break. What? What? Oh my gosh. Guys, Angela Sass coming your way.
好的，我在等。我们要休息一下，还是你先对我使用“安吉拉的傲慢”？在休息前我要对你使用“安吉拉的傲慢”。什么？什么？天哪。伙计们，“安吉拉的傲慢”要来了。
I got a hot Angela Sass card to play. Right away, seven seconds, Angela is giving side eye to Jan right out of the gate. It's true. There's going to be a lot of Angela snarky looks in this episode. Seven seconds, look for some classic side eye. And when we will go to break and then I'm going to come back, I got some more Angela sass. I'm glad you could get that off your chest out of your hands.
我有一张火热的“安吉拉的傲慢”卡要打。马上，七秒钟，安吉拉一上来就对简翻白眼。这是真的。这一集里会有很多安吉拉刻薄的表情。七秒钟，寻找一些经典的白眼。然后我们会休息，然后我会回来，我还有更多的“安吉拉的傲慢”。我很高兴你能把它从胸口和手里释放出来。
Seven seconds into the episode, I'm already like sassing it out. I'm sassing it out. I'm throwing shade. Isn't that what the kids say? I think throwing shade. Do you throw shade the kids say? I think throwing shade. Do you throw shade or do you give shade? I think you throw it. We throw, or do you chunk shade?
在这一集开始七秒钟，我就已经在展现傲慢了。我在展现傲慢。我在讽刺。这不是孩子们说的吗？我想是讽刺。你讽刺是孩子们说的吗？我想是讽刺。你讽刺还是给予讽刺？我想你是抛出它。我们抛出，还是你扔出讽刺？
I think you chunk shade. You chunk shade. All right, let's go to break. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz.
我想你扔出讽刺。你扔出讽刺。好吧，让我们休息一下。通过Fizz忠诚度计划，你只需拥有一个移动套餐即可获得奖励。你知道，为了发短信之类的。如果你没有通过移动套餐获得额外数据和现金折扣等奖励，那你就不在Fizz。
Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. With tons of free reality shows, you are totally free to watch what you love on Pluto TV. And for me, that's Dance Moms, Bar Rescue, The Challenge, and Jersey Shore. All totally free on Pluto TV. Stream now, pay never.
今天就切换吧。条件适用。详情请见fizz.ca。拥有海量免费真人秀节目，你完全可以自由观看你喜爱的Pluto TV内容。对我来说，那是《舞蹈妈妈》、《吧台救援》、《挑战》和《泽西海岸》。在Pluto TV上完全免费。现在流媒体播放，永远不用付费。
Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure. Stay two nights and get a $50 Best Western gift card. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. The cold open of Boys and Girls. Let's jump in. We open on the conference room. The women
暂停你正在听的任何内容，开始你的下一次冒险。入住两晚即可获得50美元的Best Western礼品卡。生活就是一场旅行。在Best Western充分利用它。访问bestwestern.com了解完整的条款和条件。《男孩与女孩》的冷开场。让我们开始吧。我们在会议室开场。办公室里的女性
in the office are seated with Jan. Side eye. Side eye from Angela. Side eye. Side eye. Pam has a talking head where she explains it's Women in the Workplace Seminar Day and Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye.
和简坐在一起。白眼。安吉拉的白眼。白眼。白眼。帕姆有一个谈话头，她解释说是“职场女性研讨会日”，白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。
Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye.
白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。
Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. Side eye. I'm wearing light pink. Is this because you're in love with Dwight? Maybe. Is this love? This might be my love outfit. I am sporting that really low, severe ponytail, which I hated as much as the bun. Yeah. Because it pulls right at the back of your neck. I hated that ponytail.
白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。白眼。我穿着浅粉色。这是因为你爱上了德怀特吗？也许吧。这是爱吗？这可能是我的恋爱装。我留着那个非常低、严厉的马尾辫，我讨厌它就像讨厌发髻一样。是的。因为它拉扯着你的后颈。我讨厌那个马尾辫。
So I think in the Valentine's Day episode, you were gray. But in this episode, you were pink. I wore like beige on beige kind of for Valentine's. All right, at 54 seconds, I screen grabbed it and Jenna, I'm going to show it to you. I look dead inside. What? Michael is talking about the Allie McBeal woman, right? Oh yeah.
所以我认为在情人节那一集，你是灰色的。但在这一集中，你是粉色的。情人节时我穿的是米色配米色。好吧，在54秒时，我截屏了，珍娜，我要给你看。我看起来内心已死。什么？迈克尔在谈论那个《艾莉的异想世界》女人，对吧？哦，是的。
And it cuts over to my expression and I'm going to show you what I'm doing. This like cracked me up. Oh my gosh, is that your resting bitch face? I think that's my RBF. My resting, well, my resting Angela Martin face. I think this is the face I make as I walk through the grocery store and people are like, it's gonna be okay.
然后切到我的表情，我要给你看我在做什么。这让我笑死了。天哪，那是你的“冷漠脸”吗？我想那是我的RBF。我的冷漠，嗯，我的冷漠安吉拉·马丁脸。我想这就是我走过杂货店时做的表情，人们会说，一切都会好起来的。
Yeah. I'm like what? I'm happy, I'm having a great day. I think that is. Did you watch Ally McBeal? Were you an Ally McBeal fan? I'm happy. I'm having a great day. I think that is. Did you watch Ally McBeal? Were you an Ally McBeal fan? I don't think I did watch it. I don't have a big memory of watching it. I mean, maybe I caught an episode or two, but I didn't, you know.
是的。我说什么？我很开心，我今天过得很棒。我想是那样。你看过《艾莉的异想世界》吗？你是《艾莉的异想世界》的粉丝吗？我很开心。我今天过得很棒。我想是那样。你看过《艾莉的异想世界》吗？你是《艾莉的异想世界》的粉丝吗？我想我没看过。我没有关于看它的深刻记忆。我的意思是，也许我看了几集，但我没有，你知道。
Yeah. I didn't know it. I mean, when Michael says he's talking about the Ally McBeal woman and her sort of like journey, I was like, well, I don't really know what that means. So I'm going to Google Ally McBeal. Oh dear. Here is the description of Ally McBeal woman and her sort of like journey. I was like, well, I don't really know what that means. So I'm going to Google Ali McBeal. Here is the description of Ali McBeal. Okay. Ali McBeal is a young attorney who joins a prestigious law firm with a highly sexual environment and whose staff includes Ali's ex boyfriend. The series contains fantasy sequences, flashbacks and voiceovers to reveal what Allie is really thinking.
是的。我不知道。我的意思是，当迈克尔说他在谈论《艾莉的异想世界》女人和她的某种旅程时，我想，嗯，我真的不知道那是什么意思。所以我去谷歌搜索《艾莉的异想世界》。哦，亲爱的。这是关于《艾莉的异想世界》女人的描述和她的某种旅程。我想，嗯，我真的不知道那是什么意思。所以我去谷歌搜索《艾莉的异想世界》。这是《艾莉的异想世界》的描述。好的。《艾莉的异想世界》是一位年轻的律师，她加入了一家拥有高度性化环境的著名律师事务所，其员工包括艾莉的前男友。该系列包含幻想序列、闪回和画外音，以揭示艾莉真正的想法。
I was like curious when Michael said Allie McBeal. I'm like, well, I gotta look that up. I mean, I know it was a big hit show and Calista Flockhart and all that, but that's who I- Calista Flockhart is adorable. She's adorable. Okay. Next we get into the episode, the men are in the bullpen.
当迈克尔说《艾莉的异想世界》时，我很好奇。我想，嗯，我得查查。我的意思是，我知道那是一部大热剧，卡莉斯塔·弗洛克哈特等等，但那就是我——卡莉斯塔·弗洛克哈特很可爱。她很可爱。好的。接下来我们进入这一集，男人们在办公区。
Michael decides since he's been kicked out of Jan's meeting that he's going to tell the men to circle up. At two minutes, 33 seconds, there's a fan question from Lauren and Derek, who is the woman walking in the background over Dwight's shoulder? Why isn't she in the meeting with Jan? Is it Luanne? It's Luanne. It's Luanne. It's Luanne. Luanne was like Creed, a background person,
迈克尔决定既然他被赶出了简的会议，他要告诉男人们围成一圈。在两分33秒，有一个来自劳伦和德里克的粉丝提问，德怀特肩膀后面走过的女人是谁？为什么她不在简的会议里？是卢安吗？是卢安。是卢安。是卢安。卢安就像克里德一样，是一个背景人物，
slash stand-in for the female actors. And I guess, I don't know why she's, it's a good point. Why is she crossing in the background? They should have told her to stand down. Good catch. I want to talk about Michael's talking head at a minute 16 seconds, because this really cracked me up. He says that women in the workplace basically means I have been banned from my own conference room so Jan can talk in secret to all the girls, sorry women. Yeah. And then he says, I don't know
兼女性演员的替身。我想，我不知道为什么她是，这是一个好点子。为什么她在背景中穿过？他们应该告诉她站住。好眼力。我想谈谈迈克尔在1分16秒的谈话头，因为这真的让我笑死了。他说职场女性基本上意味着我被禁止进入我自己的会议室，这样简就可以私下和所有的女孩，抱歉，女性交谈。是的。然后他说，我不知道
what they're going to talk about. And do you know what the two things he lists that they're probably going to talk about? What? Clothes and me. He's like, I don't know what they're gonna talk about. Probably clothes, maybe me. Ugh. Like that's not wrong. We do end up talking about clothes and him. So I mean, he nailed it. He nailed it. So during this circle up. Oh, wait, there's such a classic Creed moment. There's such a classic Creed moment at two minutes 48 seconds. You guys, you have to watch this. This is just Creed being Creed, okay? No one told him to do this.
她们要谈论什么。你知道他列出的她们可能会谈论的两件事是什么吗？什么？衣服和我。他说，我不知道她们要谈论什么。可能是衣服，也许是我。呃。就像那不是错的一样。我们最终确实谈论了衣服和他。所以我的意思是，他猜对了。他猜对了。所以在这次围圈期间。哦，等等，有一个如此经典的克里德时刻。在两分48秒有一个如此经典的克里德时刻。你们，你们必须看这个。这只是克里德做克里德，好吗？没人告诉他这样做。
They wanted the men to circle up. How does Creed get there? He does this rolly thing on his chair. He like speeds by, like shoving himself along in his rolly chair and it's just hilarious. And that is all creed. So also in this time, Dwight makes a comment about how if the women stay in the conference room
他们想要男人们围成一圈。克里德是怎么到那里的？他用他的椅子做了这个滚动动作。他像飞一样经过，把自己推在滚动椅上，这太搞笑了。那完全是克里德。所以在这段时间里，德怀特发表评论说，如果女性在会议室里待得
long enough, all of our periods are going to sync up. I know where you're going with this, because Jenna texted me at 11 o'clock last night. I was like, what are you doing up? And she was like, I am researching women. Whether or not women's periods really sync up if they spend a long period of time together. Here's what I found out. This theory is based on a study by a woman named Dr. Martha McClintock back in 1971.
足够久，我们所有的生理期都会同步。我知道你要去哪里，因为珍娜昨晚11点给我发了短信。我说，你还没睡在干什么？她说，我在研究女性。女性如果长时间待在一起，生理期是否真的会同步。这是我发现的。这个理论基于1971年一位名叫玛莎·麦克林托克博士的女性的研究。
You guys welcome to office ladies. We're going to read to you who Ali McBeal is and talk about menstruation. She studied a group of college students living in a dorm together and what she found was that syncing did happen between roommates and close friends, but not random pairings of women. Many studies have been done since to either prove or disprove her study, and for the most part, none of them have been able to prove her study. They've all yielded sort of random results. There are a lot of mathematical charts that show how every woman will sync with another woman at some period of time in their lives
你们好，欢迎来到《办公室女士》。我们要给你们读《艾莉的异想世界》是谁，并谈论月经。她研究了一群住在一起的女大学生，她发现室友和亲密朋友之间确实发生了同步，但不是随机配对的女性。自那以后进行了许多研究来证明或反驳她的研究，在很大程度上，没有一项能够证明她的研究。它们都产生了某种随机的结果。有很多数学图表显示每个女性在她们生命中的某个时期都会与另一个女性同步，
just because of statistics. But this idea that four women who live in a house together for three years are for three years going to have their periods synced seems to be debunked. Well, you heard it here, everybody. You heard it here. To give you more information, because I know that's what you're craving, there is a theory that there's something called an alpha womb and a beta womb. I really feel like Dwight should have talked about this.
仅仅因为统计学。但这种四个住在一起三年的女性，三年来生理期都会同步的想法似乎被揭穿了。好吧，你们在这里听到了，各位。你们在这里听到了。为了给你们更多信息，因为我知道那是你们渴望的，有一个理论说有一种东西叫阿尔法子宫和贝塔子宫。我真的觉得德怀特应该谈谈这个。
This does sound like a Dwight talking head, like, here's the thing about the alpha womb. The idea is that the cycle that they all sink to is the alpha womb and the beta wombs sink to that womb. And so one of the reasons why two women might not sink is because they're both alphas or both betas. You're welcome. I don't know how to... Yeah. Okay. You're welcome. I don't, I don't know how to, yeah. Okay. Well, what are you guys an alpha or a beta womb? I don't know.
这听起来确实像德怀特的谈话头，比如，关于阿尔法子宫的事情是这样的。想法是她们都同步到的周期是阿尔法子宫，而贝塔子宫同步到那个子宫。所以两个女性可能不同步的原因之一是因为她们都是阿尔法或都是贝塔。不客气。我不知道怎么……是的。好的。不客气。我不知道，我不知道怎么……是的。好的。好吧，你们是阿尔法还是贝塔子宫？我不知道。
So now Michael wants to do his own workplace seminar, right? Because he's like a little kid and he's like, well, I can't be in there. I'm gonna do my own thing. And he makes the guys clap loud. He's just being annoying. So Jan is gonna kick him out. But guys, there's something we have to discuss.
所以现在迈克尔想要举办他自己的职场研讨会，对吧？因为他像个小孩子，他说，好吧，我不能在那里面。我要做我自己的事情。他让男人们大声鼓掌。他只是很烦人。所以简要赶他走。但伙计们，有些事情我们必须讨论。
At three minutes, 11 seconds. Did we just find out how Michael pees? I think this is kind of a big sitting down. Does he pee sitting down? Why does society force us to use urinals when sitting down is far more comfortable? I think Michael sits down to pee. I don't understand why more men don't. I think we found out that he sits down to pee. I think since the invention of iPhones, more men do sit down to pee because they check their phones. Is that true guys? Is that a thing? Sam, is it true? I would say yeah, that and the invention of squatty potties. Squatty potties. There you go. You know a squatty potty, right? I know a squatty potty. Yeah. Because I listen to Howard Stern and he talks about his squatty potty.
在三分11秒。我们刚刚发现迈克尔是怎么小便的吗？我觉得这是一个很大的坐下来。他坐着小便吗？为什么社会强迫我们使用小便池，而坐着小便要舒服得多？我想迈克尔坐着小便。我不明白为什么更多的男人不这样做。我想我们发现他坐着小便。我想自从iPhone发明以来，更多的男人确实坐着小便，因为他们看手机。这是真的吗，伙计们？这是真的吗？萨姆，是真的吗？我会说是的，那和蹲式马桶的发明。蹲式马桶。给你。你知道蹲式马桶，对吧？我知道蹲式马桶。是的。因为我听霍华德·斯特恩的节目，他谈论他的蹲式马桶。
Jan wants to kick the guys out. Michael says they have nowhere to go. Dwight suggests the warehouse. Oh, it's Dwight that suggests the warehouse. Well then they all walk out the front door. Many people pointed out that Toby didn't go in the warehouse. And I loved this. I felt like this was because they've been listening to office ladies.
简想把男人们赶走。迈克尔说他们无处可去。德怀特建议去仓库。哦，是德怀特建议去仓库的。好吧，然后他们都走出了前门。许多人指出托比没有去仓库。我喜欢这个。我觉得这是因为他们一直在听《办公室女士》。
A lot of people wondered if it was so he could be in the writer's room. Yes, guys. Yes. That's exactly why. Yes, you're with us. You're with us. Guys, did you catch that Michael refers to the warehouse
很多人想知道这是否是为了让他能待在编剧室里。是的，伙计们。是的。这就是原因。是的，你和我们在一起。你和我们在一起。伙计们，你们注意到迈克尔把仓库称为
as the bowels of the office? Did you guys catch that? Speaking of squatty bodies, guess who looked up the definition of the word bowels last night? What happened to you? I don last night? What happened to you? I don't know. What happened to you, Alfa-Womb? We're both looking up crazy shiitake last night. I love Jenna when they go to the warehouse at four minutes, 13 seconds, all the guys,
办公室的肠道了吗？你们注意到了吗？说到蹲式马桶，猜猜昨晚是谁查了“肠道”这个词的定义？你昨晚怎么了？我不知道。你怎么了，阿尔法子宫？我们昨晚都在查疯狂的香菇。我喜欢珍娜，当他们在四分13秒去仓库时，所有的男人们，
seven guys are all crammed at the top of that stairwell that you and I both know leads nowhere. Yes, I noted this as well. It's basically a broom closet that they just had to pile out of. That's why they're all just standing on the landing in front of the door, because that's just a little broom closet there. You can't fit that many people in there. Then we have this amazing shot of the guys all coming down into the warehouse. I don't know how they got this.
七个男人都挤在那段你我都认识的通往虚无的楼梯间里。是的，我也注意到了这一点。这基本上是一个扫帚间，他们只是不得不挤出来。这就是为什么他们都站在门前的平台上，因为那只是一个小扫帚间。你塞不下那么多人。然后我们有了男人们都走进仓库的这个惊人镜头。我不知道他们是怎么得到这个的。
Was there a camera on a crane or something? No. They're going down and Dwight says, remember in Lost when they meet the others? And then it just pans down. How did they get that shot? I don't know. I thought it was impressive. It's a really beautiful shot. Don't tell me you watched Lost. I loved Lost. Did you watch Lost?? Oh yeah, when it was on originally. I didn't watch it last night. Oh, yeah, I watched it originally. I might have watched a few trailers and episode clips
是不是有摄像机在起重机上什么的？不。他们走下去，德怀特说，记得《迷失》里他们遇到其他人的时候吗？然后它就平移下去了。他们是怎么得到那个镜头的？我不知道。我觉得这令人印象深刻。这是一个非常美丽的镜头。别告诉我你看过《迷失》。我喜欢《迷失》。你看过《迷失》吗？？哦，是的，当它最初播出时。我昨晚没看。哦，是的，我最初看了。我昨晚可能看了几个预告片和剧集片段，
last night, just to remind myself. But were you Sawyer or Dr. Jack Shepherd? Oh boy. Right? I went back and forth. I did too. So Michael goes down to the warehouse, and he starts introducing the warehouse crew, which
只是为了提醒自己。但你是索耶还是杰克·谢泼德医生？哦，男孩。对吧？我来回摇摆。我也一样。所以迈克尔下到仓库，他开始介绍仓库工作人员，这
I thought was really interesting, as if everyone doesn't know one another. But they do. Maybe this is for our audience to remind them. Or maybe it's Michael's nod to the camera. Yes. Because he's very aware of the camera. And then he is talking to Roy Roy and he refers to Pam and Roy as the Brangelina of the office.
我觉得非常有趣，好像大家都不认识彼此一样。但他们认识。也许这是为了提醒我们的观众。或者也许这是迈克尔对摄像机的点头。是的。因为他非常意识到摄像机的存在。然后他在和罗伊说话，他把帕姆和罗伊称为办公室的布拉德·皮特和安吉丽娜·朱莉。
David Denman looks legitimately confused. He does. He looks like Roy in this moment doesn't look like he's the sharpest tool in the shed. He's like, why? And then Michael says, you're Ram. Ram. Ram. Now here's a question. I've seen debate online. Some people refer to Jim and Pam as jam. Yeah. And some people refer to them as PB and J, Pam Beasley and Jim. Yeah. What do you think is right? Because I'm a jam person. I like jam. I jam. Because it's just easier to say. I like jam.
大卫·丹曼看起来确实很困惑。他确实。他看起来像罗伊，在这一刻看起来不像他是最聪明的人。他说，为什么？然后迈克尔说，你是拉姆。拉姆。拉姆。现在有个问题。我在网上看到过争论。有些人把吉姆和帕姆称为“果酱”。是的。有些人把他们称为“PB和J”，帕姆·比斯利和吉姆。是的。你认为什么是对的？因为我是“果酱”派。我喜欢果酱。我“果酱”。因为这更容易说。我喜欢果酱。
I like Duangela. Yeah. I guess Ram or they could have been Poi. I hope not. Poi. Oh my gosh. I ship Poi. Well, you know what Roy's last name is.
我喜欢“杜安吉拉”。是的。我猜拉姆或者他们本可以是“Poi”。我希望不是。Poi。天哪。我支持Poi。好吧，你知道罗伊的姓是什么。
This is going to come up in a later episode. Roy's last name is Anderson. So when she marries Roy, her name is going to be Pamela Anderson. Did you know that? Yes, I just remembered that. That makes me laugh. So now we have a scene between Kevin and Jim. And Kevin comes up to Jim and says, I bet Roy is going to beat you up because he heard about your feelings for Pam. And this is true.
这会在后面的一集中出现。罗伊的姓是安德森。所以当她嫁给罗伊时，她的名字将是帕梅拉·安德森。你知道吗？是的，我刚刚记起来。这让我笑了。所以现在我们有凯文和吉姆之间的一场戏。凯文走到吉姆面前说，我打赌罗伊会揍你，因为他听说了你对帕姆的感情。这是真的。
This is the first time that Jim and Roy are gonna be in close proximity since it was revealed that Jim, quote unquote, used to have a crush on Pam. There's gonna be a lot of tension now for Jim down in the warehouse. But Kevin says he's got his back, but just try not to get into it.
这是自揭露吉姆“曾经”暗恋帕姆以来，吉姆和罗伊第一次近距离接触。现在吉姆在仓库里会有很多紧张感。但凯文说他会支持他，但尽量不要卷入其中。
Yeah, exactly. Try not to go there. Wait, I have a question for you. I have a performance question. So when we cut back to the conference room where the women are, Pam has a notepad. And Jan looks at her and goes, are you OK with taking notes? Can you do that?
是的，没错。尽量不要去那里。等等，我有个问题要问你。我有个表演问题。所以当我们切回女性所在的会议室时，帕姆有一个记事本。简看着她说，你介意做笔记吗？你能那样做吗？
Thank you very much. Can you take notes? Yeah. And you have this expression as Pam. I don't know. For me, Jenna, in that moment, to me, it was like, oh my God, here, it's not Michael, but once again, I'm just the secretary.
非常感谢。你能做笔记吗？是的。你作为帕姆有这个表情。我不知道。对我来说，珍娜，在那一刻，对我来说，就像，哦，天哪，在这里，不是迈克尔，但我又一次只是秘书。
It's so interesting you point this out, because we got a lot of mail about this. We did? A lot of people pointed out this moment about my discontent, I guess, at being asked to take notes. And I think, yes, I think I thought that this was a women in the workplace seminar. And now, I guess, really, am I participating in the seminar
你指出这一点非常有趣，因为我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。我们收到了吗？很多人指出了关于我被要求做笔记时的不满，我想。我想，是的，我想这本来是一个职场女性研讨会。现在，我想，真的，我是在参加研讨会
or am I taking notes for the seminar? And to be fair, you look busy the whole time, but you're just drawing a picture. I'm just drawing a picture. I'm not actually taking any notes. Well, Jan also suggests that everyone say something they're good at. Yes.
还是我在为研讨会做笔记？公平地说，你一直看起来很忙，但你只是在画画。我只是在画画。我实际上并没有做任何笔记。好吧，简还建议每个人说出他们擅长的事情。是的。
So Meredith says supplier relations. Phyllis says she's good at computers, which causes Angela to sass out. Oh, yeah. I have it. And complain. I say at six minutes, 24 seconds, I say, really? And then an improv line is where we sort of have chatter after that.
所以梅雷迪思说供应商关系。菲利斯说她擅长电脑，这导致安吉拉展现了傲慢。哦，是的。我有它。并抱怨。我在六分24秒说，真的吗？然后即兴台词是我们之后有某种闲聊。
And I'm like, because I've seen some of your spreadsheets and that sort of mumble part was improvised. And the camera pushes it on my face over you laying into Phyllis. Yeah. I did not know that that was going to happen. That's I'm calling this GIF alert. Six minutes, 27 seconds. This slow push on my face where I listen to you complain and I'm sort of giving you some side eye.
我说，因为我看过你的一些电子表格，那部分嘟囔是即兴的。摄像机推向我的脸，在你抱怨菲利斯时。是的。我不知道会发生那种事。我把这称为GIF警报。六分27秒。这个缓慢推向我脸的镜头，我听着你抱怨，我有点在给你白眼。
I see this gif constantly. This is. I know. I have a few gifs from this episode too that are out there. I want to point out something. Much the way that Toby did the shh and he backed away into the office and we know it's because Paul is going to the writer's room. In this scene, when Phyllis is saying
我经常看到这个动图。我知道。我也存了几张这一集的动图。我想指出一点。就像托比做那个“嘘”的手势然后退回办公室一样，我们知道那是因为保罗要去编剧室了。在这一幕里，当菲利斯说
she's good at computer stuff, look to her left. There's no Mindy. There's no Mindy. She's not even sitting there cause she's in the writer's room. So they kept- We would frame her out. Yeah, they would frame her out.
她很擅长电脑方面的事情时，看看她的左边。没有敏迪。没有敏迪。她甚至没坐在那儿，因为她在编剧室。所以他们保留了——我们会把她剪出画面。是的，他们会把她剪出画面。
But there's one moment where that kind of pulls just a little wide, the camera does. And you can see that she is not sitting there. She doesn't have any lines in this part, that's why. And they needed her back in the writer's room. So later on, she's there, but right in that moment, she's not there. We had a fan question from Jacob Hibbs.
但有一个镜头稍微拉远了一点，摄像机拉远了。你可以看到她没坐在那儿。她在这部分没有台词，所以才这样。他们需要她回编剧室。所以后来她在那儿，但在那一刻，她不在。我们有一个来自雅各布·希布斯的粉丝提问。
When Jan asks all the women in the office what they know they're good at, how much of the answers were improvised? None. Well, I mean, you improvised your sass to Phyllis, but the things we say we're good at were were improvised. None. Well, I mean, you improvised your sass to Phyllis, but the things we say we're good at were not improvised. No, that was all scripted. So now we go back down to the warehouse and Roy is going to confront Jim.
当简问办公室里的所有女性她们擅长什么时，有多少回答是即兴发挥的？一个都没有。嗯，我是说，你对菲利斯的刻薄是即兴的，但我们说自己擅长什么的内容是即兴的。一个都没有。嗯，我是说，你对菲利斯的刻薄是即兴的，但我们说自己擅长什么的内容不是即兴的。不，那全是剧本写的。现在我们回到仓库，罗伊要和吉姆对质了。
Yes. And they're, oh, I was on the edge of my seat for this. I know. But Roy says, hey, we're cool. And he's glad. He's glad because, you know, he's glad Pam has says, hey, we're cool. And he's glad. He's glad. He's glad because, you know, he's glad Pam has someone to talk to during the day so that she doesn't come home and like, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, to where Jim, I think that,
是的。他们，哦，我为这一幕感到紧张。我知道。但罗伊说，嘿，我们没事。他很高兴。他很高兴，因为，你知道，他很高兴帕姆有说，嘿，我们没事。他很高兴。他很高兴。他很高兴，因为，你知道，他很高兴帕姆有可以聊天的人，这样她回家就不会像，哒哒哒哒哒，对吉姆，我觉得，
I think he throws shade. He says, yeah, I love talking to her too. I just thought it was an honest moment. Like Jim does like talking to her, but- But he couldn't help it. Like that's so passive aggressive. I know, I know. Well, I wrote, I wrote during the scene,
我觉得他在暗讽。他说，是啊，我也喜欢和她聊天。我只是觉得这是一个真诚的时刻。吉姆确实喜欢和她聊天，但是——但他忍不住。这太被动攻击了。我知道，我知道。嗯，我写了，我在这一幕时写了，
I wrote Jenna, you are my Jim. You're who I yap, yap, yap to at work. And I'm probably Josh when I get home is like so happy that I've sort of journaled out loud to you all day. It's probably true. I've sorted out, you know, all my issues and I get home to him and then I just hang out. I've had moments where Lee has said to me, have you not talked to Angela in a while? Because I'm getting blocked.
我写道：珍娜，你是我的吉姆。你是我在工作中可以一直唠叨的对象。当我回家时，我可能就是乔什，他很高兴我一整天都像是在对你进行口头日记。这可能是真的。我整理了，你知道，我所有的问题，然后我回到他身边，我就只是待着。我有过几次李对我说，你是不是很久没和安吉拉说话了？因为我被屏蔽了。
Lee. All right. Darrell suggests that everyone go up to the office. Well, he wants to switch places, right? He said, let's experience what the office is like. The warehouse guys go up, you guys stay here and load trucks. Yeah, but instead the sales guys start unloading the truck and he doesn't want people in his space
李。好吧。达里尔建议大家去办公室。嗯，他想换个位置，对吧？他说，让我们体验一下办公室是什么样的。仓库的人上去，你们待在这儿装货。是啊，但相反，销售人员开始卸货，他不想让人们在他的空间里，
because as you're going to see, it doesn't go well. Well, he says, Michael's like, what's your biggest fear? And he goes, that someone will come down here and distract us and mess with our stuff and we won't get anything done. Yeah. Well, Michael finds the blow up doll from the sexual harassment episode.
因为正如你将看到的，这进行得并不顺利。嗯，他说，迈克尔问，你最大的恐惧是什么？他说，有人会下来打扰我们，弄乱我们的东西，导致我们什么也做不成。是啊。嗯，迈克尔发现了性骚扰那一集里的充气娃娃。
With his face on it. Yep. Which brings me to a question, Jenna. Yes. I saw that you have a face of yourself that's being sold on Amazon. People can buy your face Yeah as a mask as a mask my face, but but not only that there were only 15 left
上面有他的脸。是的。这让我想到了一个问题，珍娜。是的。我看到亚马逊上在卖印有你脸的产品。人们可以买你的脸，是的，作为一个面具，作为一个面具，我的脸，但不仅如此，只剩下15个了。
It's almost only 15. Why did you make 15? Is there that big of a demand? I when I saw that there were 15 left. I was like you should just print these Or order. I mean you don't need a stockpile of these. Who's buying these? Well, maybe people have office parties. I don't know. They have office-themed parties. It's also a photo of you with like your hair up in a bun.
几乎只剩15个了。你为什么要制作15个？需求量真的那么大吗？当我看到只剩下15个时，我就想，你应该直接打印这些，或者订购。我是说，你不需要囤积这些。谁在买这些？嗯，也许人们有办公室派对。我不知道。他们有办公室主题派对。那也是一张你头发盘成发髻的照片。
I'm sorry, like it was- Like an updo. Yeah, it's from a, now here's what I'd understand. Legally, no one asked my permission. I'm not getting any money for that. Yeah. Are you allowed to sell someone's face? I guess so.
抱歉，就像是——就像一个盘发。是的，它来自一个，现在我明白了。从法律上讲，没人征求我的许可。我没从中得到任何钱。是的。你可以卖别人的脸吗？我想可以吧。
Maybe not. Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop. Lawyer, cease and desist. I know. I don't know. I mean, I guess they have to pay the photographer for their rights? I don't know.
也许不行。嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟。律师，停止侵权通知。我知道。我不知道。我是说，我想他们必须支付摄影师版权费吧？我不知道。
I'm not a lawyer, but I did go to pre-law. I bought the remaining 15 of your face. You didn't. And. Oh my God, that would be so scary. If I came to your house, you're all wearing that. I wallpapered my bathroom with it. Anyway, okay, where are we?
我不是律师，但我确实上过法律预科。我买了剩下的15个你的脸。你没买。而且。天哪，那太可怕了。如果我到你家，你们都戴着那个。我用它贴满了我的浴室墙纸。总之，好吧，我们在哪儿？
Well, I have a fan question. Vicki Siskie at eight minutes, 34 seconds noted, behind Dwight, there is something written on the truck's walls. Does it have any meaning? Well, Vicki, I screen grabbed it. I zoomed in on it. It looks like what is written on the wall is Co-A-E-Go. C-O-A-E-G-O. I Googled it and I couldn't find a meaning. So I think it doesn't mean anything. I wonder if it's like something kind of like how OSHA, you know, like when I worked at
嗯，我有一个粉丝提问。薇琪·西斯基在8分34秒时指出，德怀特身后，卡车墙上写着些东西。它有什么含义吗？嗯，薇琪，我截屏了。我放大了看。墙上写的看起来像是Co-A-E-Go。C-O-A-E-G-O。我谷歌了一下，没找到含义。所以我认为它没有任何意义。我不知道它是否像OSHA那样，你知道，就像我在
1-800-Dennis, I have to be like, our dentists meet OSHA strict standards for occupational safety and health administration or whatever it was. But I think if you Googled OSHA, something would come up. Yes. But Co-A-E-Go, nothing. Well. But I tried. She tried, Vicki.
1-800-Dennis工作时，我必须说，我们的牙医符合OSHA职业安全与健康管理局的严格标准，或者类似的东西。但我想如果你谷歌OSHA，会有结果出来。是的。但Co-A-E-Go，什么都没有。好吧。但我试过了。她试过了，薇琪。
Sometimes I just want you guys to know I tried. Yes. And that's, and this is one of those moments. If anyone else would like to screen grab and maybe has better insight, will you email us at what coagula means? Yeah. All right. At eight minutes, 13 seconds, we're in the conference room.
有时我只是想让你们知道我试过了。是的。这就是其中一个时刻。如果还有其他人想截屏，也许有更好的见解，请发邮件告诉我们Coagula是什么意思？好的。好的。在8分13秒，我们在会议室。
Guess who's back all of a sudden. Kelly Kelly is there. And this is what we like to call full Mindy now. She has her hair down, she has a clip in her hair. She has purple nail polish, a purple blouse. She has makeup on. But it's Paisley blouse again. I know.
猜猜谁突然回来了。凯利，凯利在那儿。这就是我们现在所说的“完全敏迪”。她把头发放下来了，头发上有一个发夹。她涂了紫色指甲油，穿着紫色衬衫。她化了妆。但又是那件佩斯利花纹衬衫。我知道。
Again, where are they finding all this Paisley? I don't know. I feel like if I wanted to buy a Paisley blouse, I couldn't find one. I know, I know. Well, and she has a big speech about how she doesn't want just, you know, to schlep her kids around some minivan. She wants an SUV with three rows.
又是这样，他们从哪儿找到这么多佩斯利花纹的？我不知道。我觉得如果我想买一件佩斯利花纹衬衫，我都找不到。我知道，我知道。嗯，她有一大段演讲，说她不想只是，你知道，开着小型货车到处接送孩子。她想要一辆有三排座位的SUV。
This is the important conversation that's happening. Well, listen, I get it. Yes. Jan asks everyone to go around and say what their goals are. Yes. Meredith says, in five years, I'd like to be five years sober. I mean, four and a half. Or four and a half. Kelly wants an SUV, not a minivan. Phyllis would really love a nice big walk-in closet, which everyone is in agreement on.
这就是正在进行的重要的对话。嗯，听着，我懂。是的。简让每个人轮流说出他们的目标。是的。梅雷迪思说，五年后，我想戒酒五年。我是说，四年半。或者四年半。凯利想要SUV，而不是小型货车。菲利斯真的很想要一个漂亮的大步入式衣橱，大家都同意这一点。
Everyone's like, oh yeah, yeah. Yeah. Fan question from Laura Lynn. This is to us, Angela. Okay. What is something that both you and Angela know you're good at and what are your goals? Oh my gosh. Way to get deep, lady. I know. What comes to mind? What springs to mind? What are you good at?
大家都说，哦，是啊，是啊。是的。来自劳拉·琳恩的粉丝提问。这是给我们的，安吉拉。好的。你和安吉拉都知道自己擅长什么，你们的目标是什么？天哪。真会问深奥的问题，女士。我知道。什么浮现在脑海中？什么跳入脑海？你擅长什么？
Well- I know something you're good at. One time when I was really young, we were in church and the minister was like saying, you guys, what are your strengths? How could you help? And my friend turned to me and goes, well, you're very verbal. You're very verbal? So maybe I'm good at chatty.
嗯——我知道你擅长什么。有一次我年纪很小的时候，我们在教堂，牧师问，你们的优势是什么？你们能怎么帮忙？我的朋友转向我说，嗯，你很健谈。你很健谈？所以也许我擅长聊天。
All right. I'm going to do better than your friend in church. What? I'll tell you what you're good at chatty. All right. I'm going to do better than your friend in church. What? I'll tell you what you're good at. You are very good at bringing people together. You're very good at collecting people. Aw. But this is, I mean, like this is a true gift.
好吧。我会比你在教堂的朋友做得更好。什么？我会告诉你你擅长什么，聊天。好吧。我会比你在教堂的朋友做得更好。什么？我会告诉你你擅长什么。你非常擅长把人们聚在一起。你非常擅长收集朋友。啊。但这，我是说，这真的是一种天赋。
So you know, like how Angela told you the story about how she did this movie with Ken Jong and they were across the hall and she took him down to P.F. Chang's for his 40th birthday. That is Angela right there. But what happens is then you have so endeared yourself to people that they're with you for life and you stick with people through thick and thin. And when you go to a party at Angela's house, it is the strangest hodgepodge
所以你知道，就像安吉拉告诉你她和肯·郑拍电影的故事，他们住在走廊对面，她带他去P.F. Chang's过40岁生日。那就是安吉拉。但发生的事情是，你让人们如此喜爱你，以至于他们一生都和你在一起，你和人们同甘共苦。当你去安吉拉家参加派对时，那是你一生中见过的最奇怪的大杂烩。
of people you will ever meet in your life. And they are all the nicest, warmest, most lovely people. And this is a true talent. Your judge of character is excellent. Oh, lady. Thanks for sticking with me, by the way. Oh my gosh. I guess I sort of, that sounded like I gave myself a compliment. No. I'm in your group. Yeah. I guess I sort of, that sounded like I gave myself a compliment. No.
他们都是最友善、最热情、最可爱的人。这是一种真正的天赋。你对人的判断力非常出色。哦，女士。顺便说一句，谢谢你一直支持我。天哪。我想我刚才，听起来像是在给自己贴金。不。我在你的圈子里。是的。我想我刚才，听起来像是在给自己贴金。不。
And I'm in your group. Well, I am. But that is, that is you. You're really, really good at that. Well thanks for saying that. I, you know, I sort of have a hodgepodge of people in my life. It's like people stew, you know, people stew. I know some people, and I have very good friends that are like this, that they definitely need
而且我在你的圈子里。嗯，我是。但那就是你。你真的，真的很擅长那个。谢谢你这么说。我，你知道，我的生活中确实有一群大杂烩般的人。就像“人肉炖菜”，你知道，人肉炖菜。我知道有些人，我有很好的朋友也是这样，他们绝对需要
their friends from work and one component of their life, and then they have their lifelong family friends from growing up, and then they have, so it's like their work people, their friend people, their family people. Yeah, they keep it compartmentalized as Ed Truck would suggest. Yes, yes, and maybe I'm more Michael Scott. I just want them all together. And so if you do come to my house, you might meet my neighbor Scott and then like a friend of mine from high school who happened to be in town.
他们工作中的朋友和生活中的一个组成部分，然后他们有从小一起长大的终身家庭朋友，然后他们有，所以就像他们的工作伙伴，他们的朋友，他们的家人。是的，他们把它们分门别类，正如埃德·卡车所建议的那样。是的，是的，也许我更像迈克尔·斯科特。我只是想把他们都聚在一起。所以如果你来我家，你可能会见到我的邻居斯科特，然后还有我高中时的一个朋友，正好在城里。
It's just a little mix of everything. Yeah, it's true. Well, that was very sweet, Jenna. And then a goal? We have to talk about a goal. Yeah, what are your goals? Gosh, I really, really just wanted to have a job where I could be there to take my daughter to school and pick her up and be there for every soccer
这只是各种东西的一点混合。是的，是真的。嗯，那太贴心了，珍娜。那么目标呢？我们必须谈谈目标。是的，你的目标是什么？天哪，我真的，真的只是想拥有一份工作，让我可以去接送女儿上学，参加每一场足球
practice and everything. I think my goal is just really, I just want to be there for my family. This podcast is our goals. Yeah. We're living our goals. We're living our goals. Jenna, what
练习和所有事情。我想我的目标只是，我真的只想陪伴我的家人。这个播客就是我们的目标。是的。我们正在实现我们的目标。我们正在实现我们的目标。珍娜，
about you? You know what? I think something I'm really good at is achieving goals. I have always been that way. Even if it was like from the time I was 10 years old and I said, one day I'll go to Paris, one day I'll go to Paris. I didn't go to Paris until I was 36 years old, but I went. Yeah. And I keep a little journal with my goals and I daydream about them. And if I set my mind to it, I find a way to make it work. I don't know how I do it, but I become sort of unstoppable. You are, I think you're a force. One of the things I have said many, many times to people,
你呢？你知道吗？我想我真的很擅长实现目标。我一直都是这样。即使是从我10岁的时候开始，我说，有一天我会去巴黎，有一天我会去巴黎。我直到36岁才去巴黎，但我去了。是的。我记了一本小日记，写着我的目标，我做白日梦。如果我下定决心，我会找到方法让它实现。我不知道我是怎么做到的，但我变得势不可挡。你是，我觉得你是一股力量。我曾多次对人们说的一件事，
I was like, listen, if the shiitake goes down and I need someone to go into battle with, I'll tell you right now, it's Jenna Fisher, because she would have a very organized army. She would have thought out her strategy. We're gonna to win. I think this is why I like movies like The Edge, survivalist movies. I just saw 1917. I saw 1917.
我说，听着，如果天塌下来，我需要有人和我一起上战场，我告诉你，现在就是珍娜·费舍尔，因为她会有一支非常有组织的军队。她会想好她的策略。我们要赢。我想这就是为什么我喜欢像《边缘》这样的电影，生存主义电影。我刚看了《1917》。我看了《1917》。
I loved it. It's so good. No one told me that it's a movie about a goal and a guy just reaching a single goal. He's like, take this letter over here and deliver this letter. Good luck. Just exactly. Yeah. I forgot to tell you, you're going to literally climb over dead bodies to do it. But I love
我喜欢它。太棒了。没人告诉我这是一部关于目标和一个人实现单一目标的电影。他就像，把这封信带到那边去，把这封信送达。祝你好运。完全正确。是的。我忘了告诉你，你将不得不真的爬过尸体才能做到。但我喜欢
seeing goals realized. I love it. Okay. Where are we? Thank you for that question. I'm sorry if we like totally got off on a tangent, but that was a, that was, those are some big thought provoking questions. Yeah. I think y'all could go to your journals tonight and write down what are you good at? What are you good at? Pump yourself up.
看到目标实现。我喜欢它。好吧。我们在哪儿？谢谢你的提问。很抱歉我们完全跑题了，但那是一些发人深省的大问题。是的。我想你们今晚可以去写日记，写下你擅长什么？你擅长什么？给自己打气。
Yeah. All right. Now we go down back into the warehouse and Michael is on the forklift. LQ slash LN asked, was Steve really driving crashing the forklift or was it a stunt driver? It was Steve. It was Steve. That was 100% Steve. That was 100% Steve. And don't think he wasn't having a good time. Oh yeah. And I sort of recall that he had to go down, they gave him a little tutorial on it. Yeah, he got like lessons.
是的。好吧。现在我们回到仓库，迈克尔在叉车上。LQ斜杠LN问，是史蒂夫真的在开叉车撞东西，还是特技演员？是史蒂夫。是史蒂夫。那是100%的史蒂夫。那是100%的史蒂夫。别以为他玩得不开心。哦，是的。我记得他必须下去，他们给了他一个小教程。是的，他上了课。
Yeah. Anyone that ever had to drive it as part of the show got a little safety lesson and a tutorial on it. We did have a stunt coordinator. That was a planned event to have all the things. And I believe they practiced, not in the moment and not with things on the shelves, but the idea of how all that would work. That was a choreographed moment.
是的。任何在节目中必须驾驶它的人都接受了安全课程和教程。我们确实有一位特技协调员。那是一个计划好的活动，要发生所有的事情。我相信他们练习过，不是在那个时刻，也不是在货架上有东西的时候，而是关于这一切将如何运作的想法。那是一个编排好的时刻。
Yeah. It was not improvised. It was not improvised. Two rows of supplies fell, but it was very thought out what wased moment. Yeah. It was not improvised. It was not improvised. Two rows of supplies fell, but it was very thought out what was on those shelves and how it was gonna fall and how Steve would hit it and it would fall a certain way.
是的。那不是即兴的。那不是即兴的。两排补给品倒下了，但货架上有什么以及它将如何倒下，史蒂夫将如何撞击它，它将如何以某种方式倒下，这些都是经过深思熟虑的。
So that was a very thought out moment. There's a deleted scene that was not included, but you can find it in the deleted scenes where in addition to Michael knocking down all the shelves, Dwight gets his spud gun out of his car. Well, Dwight and Roy have a whole bonding moment over their different guns that they have. Yes, and that is also a deleted scene.
所以那是一个经过深思熟虑的时刻。有一个被删除的场景没有被包括在内，但你可以在删除的场景中找到它，除了迈克尔撞倒所有货架外，德怀特从车里拿出了他的土豆枪。嗯，德怀特和罗伊因为他们拥有的不同枪支而产生了一个联谊时刻。是的，那也是一个被删除的场景。
So Dwight gets his spud gun, and then he breaks the window of Daryl's office. And I noticed that they cut that out, and then for the rest of the episode, I kept looking to see if there was ever for the rest of the episode, I kept looking to see if there was ever a shot of this broken window and I couldn't see one. They really avoided it. Way to go.
所以德怀特拿出了他的土豆枪，然后他打破了达里尔办公室的窗户。我注意到他们把它剪掉了，然后在那一集的其余部分，我一直在看是否还有在那一集的其余部分，我一直在看是否还有这个破碎窗户的镜头，但我没看到。他们真的避开了它。干得好。
Well, I think it was one thing too many, right? It's like they cannot completely destroy company property, although they do a pretty good job of it. And oh my gosh, Daryl is ticked off and Lonnie yells, damn it, Michael. Yeah. Like they are mad. I was really glad that they had that reaction. I needed like as an audience, like viewer,
嗯，我想这有点过头了，对吧？就像他们不能完全破坏公司财产，尽管他们做得相当不错。天哪，达里尔气坏了，朗尼大喊，该死，迈克尔。是的。就像他们很生气。我真的很高兴他们有那种反应。我需要作为观众，
I needed someone to be like, what the hell are you doing? Yeah. So Michael gets everyone to circle up now down in the warehouse and at nine minutes, 13 seconds, you might notice that his shirt is unbuttoned. He has taken his jacket off, his tie off. His shirt is very unbuttoned. He wants to have this guy's gripe session.
我需要有人说，你到底在干什么？是的。所以迈克尔让每个人现在在仓库里围成一圈，在9分13秒，你可能会注意到他的衬衫扣子没扣。他脱掉了外套，领带。他的衬衫扣子解开了。他想进行这次员工抱怨会议。
Yes. Fan question from Jeff the tweeter. Did they ask Steve to unbutton his shirt so that Lonnie could call him Hasselhoff or was that improvised? That was scripted. Yes. And we're missing a scene
是的。来自推特用户杰夫的粉丝提问。他们要求史蒂夫解开衬衫扣子是为了让朗尼叫他哈塞尔霍夫，还是即兴的？那是剧本写的。是的。我们漏掉了一个场景，
and it is not in the deleted scenes. And I could not find my shooting draft for this episode. If any of you guys know, because sometimes you guys know more than we do. We are not the experts. We do our best to find out information from all of our sources, but this one, I couldn't figure it out,
它不在删除的场景里。我找不到这一集的拍摄草稿。如果你们中有人知道，因为有时你们知道的比我们多。我们不是专家。我们尽力从所有来源获取信息，但这一条，我没弄明白，
but I know that the Hasselhoff moment was scripted. It was not improvised. And so there must be a scene. There's a riff on the Hasselhoff joke that's not there. Yeah, and I mean, you reached out to a few people. So we did, I know. So guys out there, if you know. I could not get the answer to, is there a missing scene?
但我知道哈塞尔霍夫的时刻是剧本写的。它不是即兴的。所以一定有一个场景。有一个关于哈塞尔霍夫笑话的即兴发挥不在那儿。是的，我是说，你联系了几个人。所以我们确实联系了，我知道。所以伙计们，如果你们知道。我没能得到答案，是不是漏掉了一个场景？
But I think there must be a scene where Michael, for whatever reason, unbuttons his shirt. I love so much that at 9 minutes 27 seconds, Madge is like, hey, do you want me to go? Because they're having a guy gripe session and Madge is sitting there. And they're just griping about women, basically. I know, I know. So back upstairs, the women are still discussing their dreams. And Pam says that her dream is to have a house with a terrace upstairs to plant flowers, a husband that she loves, Roy.
但我认为一定有一个场景，迈克尔因为某种原因解开了衬衫扣子。我非常喜欢在9分27秒，马奇说，嘿，你想让我走吗？因为他们正在进行员工抱怨会议，而马奇坐在那儿。他们基本上是在抱怨女性。我知道，我知道。所以回到楼上，女性们还在讨论她们的梦想。帕姆说她的梦想是拥有一栋带楼上露台的房子，可以种花，有一个她爱的丈夫，罗伊。
She felt like she had to say it. But then she also says that she loves to draw and she'd like to do graphic design. And Jan's face just lights up. Finally Jan perks up because she said, one of the whole purposes of this is that corporate was looking for women who might have a job position in corporate. Yes.
她觉得她必须这么说。但随后她也说她喜欢画画，想做平面设计。简的脸亮了起来。简终于振作起来了，因为她说，这整个目的之一就是公司正在寻找可能在公司有职位的女性。是的。
Yes. So Jan tells her, we have a program. And it's just on the weekends. And then there's a couple weeks in New York, but I'm sure I can make arrangements for you to go. Pam just keeps making excuses. And then Jan says, there are always a million reasons not to do something.
是的。所以简告诉她，我们有一个项目。只是在周末。然后有几周在纽约，但我肯定能为你安排好。帕姆一直在找借口。然后简说，总有一百万个理由不去尝试做某事。
Yeah. So fan question from Mother of Cats. Pam says she did a little drawing in college. Where did she go to college and for what? And Stephanie said, how did Pam become a receptionist if she went to college? Well, first of all, I went to college and I was a receptionist for seven years while I was pursuing what I went to college. Well, first of all, I went to college and I was a receptionist for seven years while I was pursuing, you know, what I went to college for. So I think it's pretty
是的。所以来自“猫之母”的粉丝提问。帕姆说她在大学里画过一点画。她去哪所大学，学什么？斯蒂芬妮说，帕姆如果上了大学，怎么会成为接待员？嗯，首先，我上了大学，我做了七年的接待员，同时我在追求我上大学所学的。嗯，首先，我上了大学，我做了七年的接待员，同时我在追求，你知道，我上大学所学的。所以我认为这很
common. I also in my PAM essay that I wrote, I had written that PAM went to a couple of years of community college, but that she did not graduate. This is my personal backstory. And she ended up getting a job in my backstory that was meant to be a placeholder, where she kind of talked herself into the fact that she needed to, you know, maybe earn some money. I think a lot of people have this conversation with themselves. I had this conversation with myself. It's how I became a secretary for seven years. I said, oh, it's just temporary. I'm just a temp.
常见。在我也写的帕姆文章中，我写道帕姆上了几年社区大学，但她没有毕业。这是我的个人背景故事。在我的背景故事中，她最终得到了一份本意是临时的工作，她有点说服自己，她需要，你知道，也许赚点钱。我想很多人都和自己进行过这种对话。我自己也进行过这种对话。这就是我做了七年秘书的原因。我说，哦，这只是暂时的。我只是个临时工。
And then I found myself working 50 hours a week as the executive secretary to a vice president of a big company and sort of ignoring my dreams. And that is exactly what's happening to Pam right now. She's become so entrenched in her kind of everyday choices that she's lost sight of the big picture. Yeah. And that very very easy to do. Yeah. And sometimes there's comfort in that too, you know. Mm-hmm. I have at 11 minutes 18 seconds, I'm calling it an adorable Phyllis moment. I love adorable Phyllis. She is so excited and she has this talking head that she's just really excited about today because she loves girl talk.
然后我发现自己每周工作50小时，担任一家大公司副总裁的执行秘书，有点忽略了我的梦想。这正是帕姆现在正在发生的事情。她已经深深陷入了她那种日常的选择中，以至于她失去了对大局的关注。是的。这非常非常容易做到。是的。有时那里面也有舒适感，你知道。嗯哼。我在11分18秒，我称之为可爱的菲利斯时刻。我喜欢可爱的菲利斯。她太兴奋了，她有这个谈话头，她今天真的很兴奋，因为她喜欢女孩间的谈话。
She loves girl talk. I just thought Phyllis was so cute in that moment. I couldn't take it. And Jan says, let's talk about clothing. Yeah. And how can we dress like where we want to go? Right. And then Angela. Yeah. Well, judging from her outfit, Jan aspires to be a whore. Do you not have a card?
她喜欢女孩间的谈话。我只是觉得菲利斯那一刻太可爱了。我受不了了。简说，我们谈谈服装吧。是的。我们怎么能穿得像我们想去的地方？对。然后安吉拉。是的。嗯，从她的穿着来看，简渴望成为一个妓女。你没有卡片吗？
This is like the biggest sass ever. Look at this. Look at this. Angela sass, eye roll. When Jan says, dress for the job you want, there is an eye roll that I get sent to me. Oh, that's your gift moment. Yeah, that's my gift moment. And then I have this talking head that I'm a professional woman.
这简直是史上最刻薄的时刻。看看这个。看看这个。安吉拉的刻薄，翻白眼。当简说，穿出你想要的工作的样子时，有一个翻白眼的镜头被发给了我。哦，那是你的动图时刻。是的，那是我的动图时刻。然后我有这个谈话头，说我是一个职业女性。
I'm in the healthiest relationship of my life. You guys, I want you to, I want you to, I want you to be a professional woman. I want you to be a professional woman. I want you to be a professional woman. I want you to be a professional woman. I want you to be a professional woman. I want you to be a professional woman. I want you to be a professional woman. I want you. And then I have this talking head that I'm a professional woman. I'm in the healthiest relationship of my life. You guys, I want you to, if you have an opportunity to re-listen to that, I did this talking head
我处于我一生中最健康的恋爱关系中。伙计们，我希望你们，我希望你们，我希望你们成为职业女性。我希望你们成为职业女性。我希望你们成为职业女性。我希望你们成为职业女性。我希望你们成为职业女性。我希望你们成为职业女性。我希望你们成为职业女性。我希望你们。然后我有这个谈话头，说我是一个职业女性。我处于我一生中最健康的恋爱关系中。伙计们，我希望你们，如果你有机会重听那一段，我做了这个谈话头
a few times because I guess whenever I said my life, I would sound really Southern. My life. So I said, I'm a professional woman. I'm in the healthiest relationship of my life. So I had to really think about it. And I can hear it ever so slightly. And then, of course, we have this awkward Dwayne Angela avoiding each other as she says that, which I loved.
几次，因为我猜每当我说“我的生活”时，我听起来会很南方。我的生活。所以我说，我是一个职业女性。我处于我一生中最健康的恋爱关系中。所以我必须认真思考它。我可以听到它非常轻微。然后，当然，我们有这个尴尬的德怀特和安吉拉互相回避的时刻，我喜欢。
I loved that little moment. But yeah, I mean, Angela thinks Jan is dressed kind of skanky for the workplace. Well, speaking of Angela and Dwight, when we go back down to the warehouse, Roy is complaining about how women want men to pay for everything. And Dwight says, yeah, they make you drive them
我喜欢那个小瞬间。但是的，我是说，安吉拉认为简在工作场所穿得有点风骚。嗯，说到安吉拉和德怀特，当我们回到仓库时，罗伊在抱怨女性如何希望男性支付一切。德怀特说，是啊，她们让你开车送她们
to church the next morning. I mean, gas ain't free. But you know what I envision is that he drives her there, but he doesn't go in. So there's just this like muscle car that pulls up in front of the church. And then Angela gets out and walks in and Dwight is like, later. Well, this is when Daryl says, we need a union. Oh, yes. And I love Craig Robinson's performance in this so much. I was texting with Craig because I really wanted him
第二天早上去教堂。我是说，汽油不是免费的。但你知道我设想的是，他开车送她去那儿，但他没进去。所以教堂前停着一辆肌肉车。然后安吉拉下车走进去，德怀特就像，回头见。嗯，这就是达里尔说，我们需要一个工会的时候。哦，是的。我非常喜欢克雷格·罗宾逊在这一集里的表演。我一直在和克雷格发短信，因为我真的很想让他
to come on this episode to talk about this moment because he's so good in it. He's so good in it, but he's filming. He's a busy guy. He couldn't do it, but he's gonna come on in the future, so don't worry. And we actually get a lot of questions from people, are you planning to have everybody on?
来这一集谈谈这个时刻，因为他演得太好了。他演得太好了，但他正在拍戏。他是个忙人。他没能来，但他以后会来的，所以别担心。我们确实从人们那里得到了很多问题，你们打算让每个人都来吗？
Yes. Yes, we would love that. Everyone. Yes, we're reaching out. Multiple times, don't worry. We have a few episodes ahead love that. Everyone. Yes, we're reaching out. Multiple times. Don't worry. We have a few episodes ahead of us. That's right. Hopefully we'll get a lot of people on. At 13 minutes, 23 seconds, during this whole scene about unions, Creed is reading a newspaper. You guys, it's the Scranton Times. That was nice. Because Phil would get the Scranton Times delivered to us.
是的。是的，我们很乐意。每个人。是的，我们正在联系。多次，别担心。我们还有几集。是的，我们正在联系。多次。别担心。我们还有几集。没错。希望我们能请到很多人。在13分23秒，在关于工会的整个场景中，克里德正在看报纸。伙计们，那是《斯克兰顿时报》。那很好。因为菲尔会把《斯克兰顿时报》送到我们这儿。
Phil Shea. Phil Shea, prop master. And so whenever there was a newspaper anywhere, it was the Scranton Times. And I loved that detail then, and I love it now. I loved it. I remember reading one one time in the back of a scene, and there had been a really big snow storm. And I was reading about the snow in Pennsylvania.
菲尔·谢。菲尔·谢，道具师。所以每当有报纸在任何地方时，它就是《斯克兰顿时报》。我当时喜欢那个细节，现在也喜欢。我喜欢它。我记得有一次在场景后面读过一份，当时有一场非常大的暴风雪。我正在读关于宾夕法尼亚州雪灾的新闻。
Yeah. All right, well, things are about to really heat up. There's gonna be some tension. Yeah, should we take a break? Let's take a break and then we're gonna get into it. All right. ["The Happy Face killer? He's my father. It's so good to see you, Missy. Experience the thrilling new series.
是的。好吧，事情真的要升温了。会有一些紧张气氛。是的，我们要休息一下吗？让我们休息一下，然后我们要深入探讨。好的。["笑脸杀手？他是我父亲。很高兴见到你，米西。体验惊心动魄的新剧集。
He said he killed another woman. Inspired by a true life story. If I don't deal with him, he will never leave us alone. You don't see how the words sing to you. Anna Lee Ashford and Dennis Quaid star. I am not responsible for what my dad did. It's going how you hoped. Happy Face new series next week. Same to you. Anna Lee Ashford and Dennis Quaid star. I am not responsible for what my dad did.
他说他又杀了一个女人。灵感来自真实生活故事。如果我不处理他，他永远不会放过我们。你没看到这些话是怎么对你唱歌的吗？安娜·李·阿什福德和丹尼斯·奎德主演。我不对我的父亲所做的事情负责。进展如你所愿。笑脸新剧集下周播出。你也一样。安娜·李·阿什福德和丹尼斯·奎德主演。我不对我的父亲所做的事情负责。
Let's go on how you hoped. Happy Face, new series now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus. and expansion into foreign markets. And we can talk all day about streamlining manufacturing processes. Because at Desjardins Business, we speak the same language you do. Business. So join the more than 400,000 Canadian entrepreneurs who already count on us and contact Desjardins today. We'd love to talk. Business.
让我们继续如你所愿。笑脸，新剧集现在在派拉蒙Plus独家流媒体播放。以及向外国市场的扩张。我们可以整天谈论简化制造流程。因为在德雅尔丹商业，我们说的是和你一样的语言。商业。所以加入已经依赖我们的40多万加拿大企业家，今天就联系德雅尔丹。我们很乐意谈谈。商业。
You know that feeling when you find the perfect song? Imagine that, but for your next meal at Tim's. Whether you're craving something meaty, cheesy, or just straight up satisfying, make a meal of it with Tim's new 3-Meat Hat Trick Flatbread Pizza, loaded with pepperoni, bacon, and sausage crumble. Pair it with our new garlic bread and a refreshing peach lemonade quencher for a meal that just hits. Order on the Tim's app today at participating restaurants in Canada for a limited time.
你知道找到完美歌曲时的那种感觉吗？想象一下，但在蒂姆家吃下一顿饭时也是如此。无论你是渴望肉食、奶酪，还是仅仅是满足感，用蒂姆家新的三肉帽子戏法平底披萨来饱餐一顿吧，上面铺满了意大利辣香肠、培根和香肠碎。搭配我们新的大蒜面包和清爽的桃子柠檬水，享受一顿美味。今天就在蒂姆应用程序上订购，在加拿大参与活动的餐厅限时供应。
We are back, but I'm the only one talking because Angela is being silent. Angela, I need to talk about your hair today. I'm sorry. It is a hot mess. What happened to you? I showered this morning before I took Isabel to school. And my goal was to show up here clean. You are clean.
我们回来了，但只有我在说话，因为安吉拉保持沉默。安吉拉，我今天得谈谈你的头发。抱歉。这简直是一团糟。你怎么了？我今天早上在送伊莎贝尔上学前洗了澡。我的目标是干净地出现在这里。你是干净的。
That's as far as I got. So I got Isabel to school on time. I was really happy about that. And I drove here with wet hair and I was like, oh, I'll freeze. I will freeze there. It's so cold. So I kind of put my window down
这就是我能做到的全部。所以我准时送伊莎贝尔上学了。我对此真的很开心。我开车来这儿时头发还是湿的，我就想，哦，我会冻僵的。我会冻僵的。太冷了。所以我把窗户降下来
and I let the wind kind of dry my hair. This is explaining it all. And now I have this wind dried hair from the freeway. Yeah, you do. I do. I do guys. And you know what? I feel fantastic.
让风把我的头发吹干。这解释了一切。现在我有这头从高速公路上吹干的头发。是的，你有。我有。我有，伙计们。你知道吗？我感觉棒极了。
I, you know, I love it. I know I love it. I look like Medusa a little bit, you know, but it's dry and I'm not cold and I'm clean and I got to go to school on time. Goals. Okay. When we come back, Michael busts into the women's meeting to tell Jan that the warehouse wants to start a union.
我，你知道，我喜欢它。我知道我看起来有点像美杜莎，你知道，但它是干的，我不冷，我很干净，而且我准时送孩子上学了。目标。好的。当我们回来时，迈克尔闯入女性会议，告诉简仓库想要成立工会。
And Jan is like, Michael, no. There cannot be a union. You didn't agree to this, right, Michael? Like the men in the warehouse weren't chanting Michael, Michael, just two minutes ago, right? And he's like, no, I definitely. He says something that would have made me go nuts. He says, okay, don't be hysterical.
简就像，迈克尔，不。不能有工会。你没同意这个，对吧，迈克尔？就像仓库里的男人们两分钟前没有高喊迈克尔，迈克尔一样，对吧？他说，不，我绝对。他说了一些会让我发疯的话。他说，好吧，别歇斯底里。
Oh yeah. That's like you need to calm down. That's like one of those kinds of phrases. Yeah, that's a trigger. That's a trigger for sure. And Pam, your reaction is hilarious. Once again, you have all of these facial reactions. I had so much fun during this episode.
哦，是的。那就像是你需要冷静下来。那就像是那种短语之一。是的，那是触发点。那绝对是一个触发点。帕姆，你的反应太搞笑了。再一次，你有所有这些面部反应。我在这一集里玩得很开心。
Well, when we go down to the warehouse again, I loved this moment. The scene when the sales guys are unpacking the truck and Ryan says, you guys, we could get this job quicker if we form an assembly line. And Stanley cuts him off and says, this is a run out the clock situation, just like upstairs. I'm gonna break it down to you, kid.
嗯，当我们再次回到仓库时，我喜欢这个时刻。当销售人员在拆开卡车包装时，瑞安说，伙计们，如果我们组成流水线，我们可以更快完成这项工作。斯坦利打断他说，这是一种拖延时间的局面，就像楼上一样。我要给你拆解一下，孩子。
This is how we're doing this. We are not going to hypothesize on how to be more efficient. This is just what gets done gets done. Run out the clock. Run out the clock situation. I was watching this with my daughter, and she goes, mom, what does he mean? And I said, Isabel, he wants to do the bare minimum.
我们就是这么做的。我们不会假设如何提高效率。这就是做完就做完。拖延时间。拖延时间的局面。我和我女儿一起看这个，她说，妈妈，他是什么意思？我说，伊莎贝尔，他想做最起码的事情。
The bare minimum. She was like, I kind of get that. I get it. I've been in a lot of run out the clock situations. So when we go back upstairs, Jan starts explaining sports terms. Sports metaphors. To the women.
最起码的事情。她就像，我有点明白了。我懂了。我经历过很多拖延时间的局面。所以当我们回到楼上时，简开始解释体育术语。体育隐喻。给女性们。
It's how women might be left out in the workplace. I'm like, is this the 1950s? I know. This was so dated. This felt like a little bit like it was out of like some manual, like from 1953 or something. Well at this point, Kelly pretends like she doesn't know what second base means. She says, okay, well, Michael said he got to second base with you.
这就是女性在工作场所可能被排斥的方式。我心想，这是1950年代吗？我知道。这太老套了。这感觉有点像来自1953年的手册之类的东西。嗯，在这一点上，凯利假装不知道二垒是什么意思。她说，好吧，迈克尔说他和你有过二垒接触。
Does that mean you closed a sale? Is that what second base means? Guess what happened? And this is a real rare thing. This is like seeing an albino rhino in the wild. What? Angela laughs! Yes! 15 minutes 10 seconds. Fan question from Jeff Ackerman. He pointed it out. There is a cutaway shot of Pam and Angela after Kelly plays dumb and asks Jan what second base means. Was that scripted or was it so funny
那意味着你完成了一笔交易吗？二垒就是这个意思吗？猜猜发生了什么？这是一件非常罕见的事情。这就像在野外看到白化犀牛。什么？安吉拉笑了！是的！15分10秒。来自杰夫·阿克曼的粉丝提问。他指出了这一点。在凯利装傻问简二垒是什么意思后，有一个帕姆和安吉拉的切镜头。那是剧本写的，还是太好笑了
you couldn't keep a straight face? That is me and Angela laughing. We're laughing, we're laughing. But I also knew that my character really thought that Jan was just like, well, she says she looks horish. So she clearly doesn't think highly of Jan and judges her. And so for Kelly to call her out, Angela thoroughly enjoyed that moment.
你无法保持严肃的表情？那是我和安吉拉在笑。我们在笑，我们在笑。但我也知道我的角色真的认为简只是，嗯，她说她看起来像个妓女。所以她显然对简评价不高，并评判她。所以对于凯利叫板她，安吉拉非常享受那一刻。
I have an observation about this episode. Oh, yes. And I'm gonna get right up on my soapbox and shout it. Here we go, here we go. While re-watching this episode, I noticed that the people who are hardest on Jan and her ambition are other women. Other women, Angela calls her a slut
我对这一集有一个观察。哦，是的。我要直接站上我的肥皂箱大声说出来。开始了，开始了。在重看这一集时，我注意到对简和她的野心最苛刻的人是其他女性。其他女性，安吉拉称她为荡妇
for the way she dresses, Pam is constantly rolling her eyes at her, and then Kelly shames her slash embarrasses her for making out with Michael. Then they lay into her for not being a mother. Oftentimes it is other women who make ambition hardest for women. I wondered if BJ intended to point this out or if it was a happy accident, because you know what?
因为她的穿着，帕姆一直在对她翻白眼，然后凯利因为她和迈克尔亲热而羞辱她。然后她们因为她不是一个母亲而攻击她。通常是其他女性让女性的野心变得最困难。我想知道BJ是否有意指出这一点，还是一个快乐的意外，因为你知道吗？
Jan is so excited to help Pam. She wants to help these other women rise up. She is so excited. Now listen, I think that it is totally valid when Phyllis says, I'm happy with my choices. We don't all need to be you. Not all women or all people need to be ambitious or share ambitions, but they are really hard on her and unaccepting of her for wanting to be her. Phyllisyllis is like, I'm gonna be me, but then they're kind of hard on Jan for being Jan.
简非常兴奋能帮助帕姆。她想帮助这些其他女性崛起。她太兴奋了。现在听着，我认为当菲利斯说，我对我的选择很满意时，这是完全合理的。我们不需要都成为你。并非所有女性或所有人都需要有野心或分享野心，但她们对她真的很苛刻，不接受她想要成为她自己。菲利斯就像，我要做我自己，但她们对简做简有点苛刻。
Well, I think Phyllis is probably the most fair of everyone. True. She's really happy with her life choices and stands by them and is unapologetic and has a very happy life. And I don't think that she wishes for Jan not to have anything. I think Phyllis is happy that Jan has chosen her path, but everyone else in the room is snarky towards Jan.
嗯，我认为菲利斯可能是所有人中最公平的。真的。她对自己的生活选择非常满意，并坚持这些选择，不道歉，过着非常幸福的生活。我不认为她希望简一无所有。我认为菲利斯很高兴简选择了她的道路，但房间里的其他人对简都很刻薄。
Yeah. They are. And I think one of the things I love about our friendship and you and I both have like a group of female friends who are really about supporting one another and building each other up and encouraging each other. And you really need those women in your life. Yeah. You really do. Yeah.
是的。她们是。我认为我喜欢我们友谊的一点是，你和我都有一个女性朋友群体，她们真的致力于互相支持，互相建立，互相鼓励。你真的需要在你的生活中拥有那些女性。是的。你真的需要。是的。
Because that really, the momentum that women give one another is really the momentum that moves us forward. Mostly. All right, Jenna, step on down. I'm stepping down. Step down. I like it. I like what you had to say. All right. I'm off my soapbox. Well, here's a juxtaposition to your soapbox moment, which I thought was really just well said. Thanks. Here's at 15 minutes, 59 seconds. Yep. Michael puts packing peanuts into a fan. What a dick.
因为那真的，女性给予彼此的动力确实是推动我们前进的动力。大部分情况下。好吧，珍娜，下来吧。我下来了。下来。我喜欢它。我喜欢你所说的。好吧。我从我的肥皂箱上下来了。嗯，这是对你肥皂箱时刻的并置，我觉得说得真的很好。谢谢。这是在15分59秒。是的。迈克尔把包装花生放进风扇里。真是个混蛋。
seconds. Michael puts packing peanuts into a fan. What a dick. That's what I had to say. That's my deep thought. Well, Jan gets so annoyed that she goes down to the warehouse. And this is when Jan tells the warehouse that if they unionize, they're all going to lose their jobs. Very, very, very anti-union. Yes. And I read, actually, that this episode has been used in law classes that deal with companies who have unions and who want to form unions, and that it has been used to show the pressure and the hard road that they can have in those moments. All right, guys, we're going to get into some sad times now
秒。迈克尔把包装花生放进风扇里。真是个混蛋。这就是我要说的。这是我的深思。嗯，简变得非常恼火，以至于她下到仓库。这就是简告诉仓库，如果他们成立工会，他们都会失去工作的时候。非常非常非常反工会。是的。我读到，实际上，这一集被用于处理有工会和想要成立工会的公司的法律课程，它被用来展示他们在那些时刻可能面临的压力和艰难道路。好了，伙计们，我们现在要进入一些悲伤的时刻了
for Jim and Pam. Oh, boy. Yeah. Jim comes upstairs to make a phone call. Pam excuses herself from her meeting, and she very excitedly tells Jim about this internship opportunity in graphic design. Jim, adorably, encourages her immediately.
关于吉姆和帕姆。天哪。是的。吉姆上楼去打电话。帕姆借故离开了会议，她非常兴奋地告诉吉姆关于那个平面设计实习机会的事。吉姆非常可爱，立刻鼓励了她。
He's like, well, what are the details? I think you should do it. I know. And she just lights up. She needed someone to give her permission in a way to go for this. And Jim immediately did. Yes. He's her soulmate.
他说，嗯，细节是什么？我觉得你应该去做。我知道。她整个人都亮了起来。在某种程度上，她需要有人给她许可去追求这个机会。而吉姆立刻就给了。是的。他是她的灵魂伴侣。
Yes. So you kind of get the sense she's going to go for it. But then you see a scene. It's a spy shot. There's no dialogue. She's holding the pamphlet. She's telling Roy about the program. And it's very clear that he is not supportive.
是的。所以你大概能感觉到她会去争取。但随后你看到了一个场景。这是一个偷拍镜头。没有对话。她拿着宣传册。她正在告诉罗伊关于这个项目的事。很明显，他并不支持。
He sees it as a waste of time. So we cut to this Pam talking head and she starts talking about this house with a terrace. Oh, this house with a terrace. This this metaphor broke my heart. Yeah, she says she was a little girl, and she read this book, and there was a house with a terrace with flowers. And she describes it in detail, and she says,
他认为这是在浪费时间。所以镜头切到了帕姆的采访，她开始谈论那个带露台的房子。哦，那个带露台的房子。这个比喻让我心碎。是的，她说她小时候读过一本书，书里有一座带露台和鲜花的房子。她详细地描述了它，她说，
I just always wanted that. But you know, it's just, you know. They don't even have those kind of houses in Scranton. They don't even have those in Scranton. Well, this was based on a story of mine. BJ came up to me on the set. We were working on a different episode. He was writing this episode.
我一直想要那样的房子。但你知道，这只是，你知道。斯克兰顿根本没有那种房子。斯克兰顿甚至都没有那种房子。嗯，这是基于我的一个故事。BJ在片场找到我。我们当时正在拍另一集。他正在写这一集。
And he came up to me, and he said, Jenna, I've got this moment I'm trying to write. Was there ever a dream that you had as a little girl that has gone unrealized because it seemed unrealistic to you. He said, it can be really simple though. It's a little girl's dream. And I said, yes.
他走到我面前说，珍娜，我正在写一个片段。你小时候有没有什么梦想因为看起来不切实际而没有实现？他说，可以很简单。这是一个小女孩的梦想。我说，有。
How smart is that though? I know. BJ is so smart. Isn't that such a great question? It's so wonderful. Writers, most of their job is just asking the right questions. BJ is so smart. Okay, so what your answer was?
这不是很聪明吗？我知道。BJ太聪明了。这不是一个很棒的问题吗？太美妙了。编剧们，他们大部分的工作就是问对问题。BJ太聪明了。好吧，那么你的回答是什么？
My answer was yes. When I was younger, I read this book and in the book, there was a girl who moved into a new house with her family and the house had a tower, sort of like a castle might. It was this tower room on the side of the house and there was one set of stairs that went up to it. And so there was this one circular room on the third floor of their home. And this was her space that she declared was hers to sit and think and create. And I had such a clear vision of what this tower room was. And I remember thinking to myself, one day, I'm going to have a house with a circular tower room where I will create.
我的回答是有。我小时候读过一本书，书里有个女孩和家人搬进了一栋新房子，房子有个塔楼，有点像城堡。房子侧面有一个塔楼房间，有一组楼梯通向那里。所以他们家三楼有一个圆形的房间。这是她宣称属于自己的空间，用来坐着思考和创作。我对这个塔楼房间有着非常清晰的构想。我记得当时心想，总有一天，我要拥有一栋带圆形塔楼房间的房子，在那里进行创作。
And I've never had it. And I never got it. Because who builds houses like that? I think this dream, do not let it go. I think maybe one day, one day, maybe, you know, they'll be like, you know, Jenna Fisher, she lives in a tower. She has a very normal looking house. And then next to it, she has built this tower in Missouri. Very strange. So BJ ran with that story. And that was he adapted it and he made it a terrace with flowers. But I think it's a little bit of collaboration. I think it's such a sweet story and then it broke my heart. Well, Pam then is in the kitchen with Jim. Her talking head is kind of broken up by the scene in the kitchen. And she's saying to Jim, Jim is like, wait, you're not
但我从来没有拥有过。我从来没得到过。因为谁会盖那样的房子呢？我觉得这个梦想，不要放弃。我想也许有一天，有一天，也许，你知道，他们会说，你知道，珍娜·费舍尔，她住在一个塔楼里。她有一栋看起来很普通的房子。然后在旁边，她在密苏里州盖了这个塔楼。非常奇怪。所以BJ采用了那个故事。他改编了它，把它变成了一个带鲜花的露台。但我认为这是一种合作。我觉得这是一个非常甜蜜的故事，然后它让我心碎。好吧，帕姆当时在厨房和吉姆在一起。她的采访被厨房里的场景打断了。她对吉姆说，吉姆说，等等，你不是
going to take the internship. And she's like, well, you know, like Roy said, there's no guarantee it's going to lead to anything anyway. He's like, Roy said that. And then Pam flips a switch. She's like, oh, do you have something to say? I was like, oh, dang, here we go. I know. She's hurt.
打算去实习吗。她说，嗯，你知道，就像罗伊说的，反正也没保证能带来什么结果。他说，罗伊那么说？然后帕姆的态度变了。她说，哦，你有什么想说的吗？我当时想，哦，糟糕，我们要开始了。我知道。她受伤了。
She's hurt. And it's not Jim's fault. He's speaking truth, you know? But he's holding that- She's like, I'm happy with my choices. He's holding that mirror up. That's what he does to her. Yeah. Ooh, I know.
她受伤了。这不是吉姆的错。他在说实话，你知道吗？但他拿着那个——她说，我对我的选择很满意。他在举着那面镜子。这就是他对她做的事。是的。噢，我知道。
This is an interesting fan question. Bernardo noted that Jim has a beard when he's talking to Pam in the kitchen. And I looked and he really does. He is like, very stubbly. What? So just to break up that beautiful moment. Well Jim says something that I that really stuck with me which is he says you got to take a chance on something sometime. Yeah. I thought that was like just a good thing to take away. Well we go back to the talking head and Pam just breaks down.
这是一个有趣的粉丝问题。贝尔纳多注意到吉姆在厨房和帕姆说话时留了胡子。我看了看，他确实留了。他看起来胡茬很重。什么？所以只是为了打破那个美好的时刻。嗯，吉姆说了一句让我印象深刻的话，他说你总得在某个时候冒险尝试一下。是的。我觉得那是一个很好的收获。好吧，我们回到采访，帕姆崩溃了。
She's talking about the terrorists, but we know what she's really talking about. She says, it's just not practical. You just aren't going to find that. And what she's really saying is, I'm never going to have Jim. I'm never going to have true love. I'm never going to be who I want to be. And that's underneath all of that. And also that my dreams aren't valid.
她在谈论露台，但我们知道她真正谈论的是什么。她说，这太不切实际了。你根本找不到那样的房子。她真正想说的是，我永远不会拥有吉姆。我永远不会拥有真爱。我永远无法成为我想成为的人。所有这些话背后都是这个意思。还有就是我的梦想是不被认可的。
Yeah, I don't get to even try for my dream. That's not my path. A fan question from Adam Falk, he asked, when Roy killed Pam's dream, the tears were so real. What were you thinking about? Guys, there are times as an actor where your heart just breaks for your character. I just felt her heartbreaking and it made me cry. It's in the same way where it makes you cry when you watch something.
是的，我甚至没有机会去尝试我的梦想。那不是我的路。亚当·福尔克的一个粉丝问题，他问，当罗伊扼杀了帕姆的梦想时，眼泪是那么真实。你在想什么？伙计们，作为演员，有时你的心会为你的角色感到破碎。我只是感受到了她的心碎，这让我哭了。就像你观看某些东西时会让你哭一样。
Or talk about it. Yeah. I wasn't thinking about, you know, my dead pet or something like that. I was thinking about how it must feel to have someone not encourage you to feel trapped and to feel so alone. And I thought about how the one person who was trying to help me, I just, I just pushed that person away. And that kind of makes you cry. Well, I think our show had a lot of like
或者谈论它。是的。我当时并没有在想，你知道，我死去的宠物之类的东西。我在想，当一个人不鼓励你，让你感到被困住和如此孤独时，那是什么感觉。我想到那个试图帮助我的人，我却把他推开了。这真的会让人哭。嗯，我觉得我们的剧有很多
really relatable moments like that. I mean, I know we do these crazy things like it's gonna cut to the warehouse and Dwight is making a snow angel out of packing peanuts and there's all of that. But then I feel like the heart of our show is also just these people living their lives and relationships. And I love that we have that balance. Me too. Well, speaking of the warehouse, we cut back down to the warehouse and Michael's
非常能引起共鸣的时刻。我的意思是，我知道我们做了一些疯狂的事情，比如镜头切到仓库，德怀特用包装泡沫做雪天使，诸如此类。但我感觉我们剧的核心也是这些人过着他们的生活和人际关系。我喜欢我们有这种平衡。我也是。说到仓库，我们切回仓库，迈克尔
completely destroyed it. He's wrecked it. Wrecked it. And then he just buys pizza for everyone and leaves. You know why? Because pizza is the great equalizer. That's what he says. It's the great equalizer. Well fan question from Tiffany Ironridge and Pickle Dude, how long did it take to clean up the warehouse?
完全毁了它。他把它弄得一团糟。弄得一团糟。然后他只是给每个人买了披萨就走了。你知道为什么吗？因为披萨是伟大的平衡器。他就是这么说的。它是伟大的平衡器。好吧，来自蒂芙尼·艾恩里奇和Pickle Dude的粉丝问题，清理仓库花了多长时间？
And Madeline Albrecht, I feel like this is because she listens to Office Ladies says, was it a hard day for Phil Shea and Michael Gallenberg? Oh, I love you. And I bet they love you too for just even highlighting that. Gina McAdrian said, who cleaned up the mess? Guys, it was. It was Phil Shea, Michael Gallenberg, their crews. Their crew.
还有马德琳·阿尔布雷希特，我觉得这是因为她听了《办公室女士》，她说，这对菲尔·谢和迈克尔·加伦伯格来说是艰难的一天吗？哦，我爱你们。我敢打赌他们也爱你，因为你甚至强调了这一点。吉娜·麦克阿德里安说，谁清理了烂摊子？伙计们，是他们。是菲尔·谢、迈克尔·加伦伯格和他们的团队。他们的团队。
I don't know how long it took them, but I imagine a long time. And also, I think these kind of shoots were more stressful for them because there were big prop moments that the whole scene was centered around and they had to have everything ready. When Michael opened up the bag of packing peanuts,
我不知道他们花了多久，但我猜是很长一段时间。而且，我认为这种拍摄对他们来说压力更大，因为有重要的道具时刻，整个场景都围绕着这些道具，他们必须准备好一切。当迈克尔打开那袋包装泡沫时，
they had to have a backup one. They had to have all of that ready to go. If you get a chance, watch the deleted scenes. There is one that I loved so much in this. It has nothing to do with this episode, really the story at all. Michael is trying to set his ringtone. Oh, and he's asking Pam to help him pick a ringtone.
他们必须准备一个备用的。他们必须准备好一切。如果有机会，看看删减片段。这里面有一个我非常喜欢的片段。它与这一集完全无关，真的与故事一点关系都没有。迈克尔正试图设置他的铃声。哦，他在请帕姆帮他选一个铃声。
Yes, and Jim is there too. And it's just these little small ridiculous moments that crack me up. We had a lot of those that we would shoot. They were just office life moments. Yeah. And so often those were the things that would have to get cut for time. I know. moments. And so often those were the things that would have to get cut for time. But they're now a treasure living on the DVD extras. At 19 minutes 52 seconds, I want you to notice,
是的，吉姆也在那里。这些小而荒谬的时刻让我笑个不停。我们拍了很多这样的镜头。它们只是办公室生活的瞬间。是的。通常这些片段为了时长不得不被剪掉。我知道。时刻。通常这些片段为了时长不得不被剪掉。但它们现在是DVD花絮中的宝藏。在19分52秒，我想让你注意，
we imply that everyone from the warehouse is walking back upstairs. I want you to notice that just Michael, Kevin and Dwight go into the door at the top of the stairs. That's again, because it's just a closet and that was as many people as they could fit. Right. And that was tight. And then in the next shot, you see them walking into the office. Michael's carrying a pizza. But we shot that on a completely different day. Yeah. So Veda, our script supervisor, she would have written down which hand Michael
我们暗示仓库里的每个人都在走回楼上。我想让你注意，只有迈克尔、凯文和德怀特走进了楼梯顶部的门。那是因为那只是个壁橱，那是他们能容纳的最多人数。没错。而且很挤。然后在下一个镜头，你看到他们走进办公室。迈克尔拿着披萨。但我们是在完全不同的一天拍摄的。是的。所以维达，我们的剧本主管，她会记下迈克尔
was carrying the pizza box in so that she could hand him that pizza box then on the next day and say, all right, here it is. Although sometimes they would have conversations that were like, well, I could believe that you switched hands on the way up. I would have deep conversations. We would have deep conversations. Do you think he switched the pizza box from one hand to the other while he was walking? I think maybe he had to use that hand to open the door. Yes, exactly.
是用哪只手拿着披萨盒的，这样她就能在第二天把那个披萨盒递给他，说，好了，给你。虽然有时他们会进行对话，比如，嗯，我可以相信你在上楼的路上换了手。我会进行深入的对话。你觉得他在走的时候把披萨盒从一只手换到了另一只手吗？我想也许他必须用那只手去开门。是的，完全正确。
Yeah, exactly. So perhaps, you know what? It's fine. You can carry it in either hand. Well, I was really bummed that at the Women in the Workplace there was no food because I was really excited that we might have pizza too. This was Jan's big fail. So she would have just fed us snacks or something. But you know, Mindy and I at Helms, we love prop food. Well, this episode ends with Pam answering the phone. Dunder Mifflin. This is Pam. And this is really significant because in her fight with Jim, he says to her, what do you really want to be a receptionist your whole life?
是的，完全正确。所以也许，你知道吗？没关系。你可以用任何一只手拿着它。嗯，我真的很沮丧，在“职场女性”那一集里没有食物，因为我真的很兴奋我们可能也会有披萨。这是简的一次大失败。所以她本可以只给我们吃零食之类的。但你知道，明迪和我，我们喜欢道具食物。好吧，这一集以帕姆接电话结束。邓德·米夫林。我是帕姆。这非常有意义，因为在她和吉姆的争吵中，他对她说，你真的想一辈子当接待员吗？
And so we end with her being a receptionist. And she just looks at him. Yeah. There's this moment. It's unresolved. Their fight is unresolved. And that's it. That's boys and girls.
所以我们以她作为接待员结束。她只是看着他。是的。有这样一个时刻。它是未解决的。他们的争吵没有解决。这就是“男孩和女孩”这一集。
Now, we have a fan request. Let me know what you think. CG wrote in to say, I would really love for you guys to keep track, because we've been tracking things, of when Jim changes from classic fit to slim fit shirts. Oh, he has such a baggy shirt. I noticed that in this episode.
现在，我们有一个粉丝请求。让我知道你们怎么想。CG写信说，我真的很希望你们能追踪一下，因为我们一直在追踪，吉姆什么时候从经典款衬衫换成了修身款衬衫。哦，他的衬衫太宽松了。我在这一集里注意到了。
There's a shot of him, he's kind of reclined back eating his pizza and his shirt's untucked. And I'm like, that shirt, it looks like it's the 90s where everyone's clothes was like three sizes too big for them. Yeah, you're gonna notice eventually, and we'll talk about this, Pam stops wearing her hair in a clip,
有一个他的镜头，他靠在后面吃披萨，衬衫没塞进裤子里。我心想，那件衬衫，看起来像是90年代，当时每个人的衣服都比他们大三个码。是的，你最终会注意到的，我们会谈论这个，帕姆不再用发夹夹头发了，
Jim stops having a shaggy hairdo, and he starts getting some like better fitting suits. I agree. So we'll be clocking all of that. You guys, we're gonna track it all. We're gonna track it all. Track it, hashtag track it. We're gonna track it all. Track it. Hashtag track it.
吉姆不再留那种蓬乱的发型，他开始穿一些更合身的西装。我同意。所以我们会记录所有这些。伙计们，我们要追踪这一切。我们要追踪这一切。追踪它，标签追踪它。我们要追踪这一切。追踪它。标签追踪它。
Hashtag track it. Okay, next week is the Valentine's episode, you guys. It's a really good one. I can't wait. Thanks for joining us. All right, we'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created
标签追踪它。好的，下周是情人节那一集，伙计们。那是非常好的一集。我等不及了。感谢加入我们。好的，我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是
in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。